O'CLOCK SO WE WILL GET STARTED
AND HOPEFULLY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
JOIN US WHEN THEY HEAR US ON
THEIR SCREENS THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL- THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM IN OUR COUNTRY
CONTINUES TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
ATTACKS FROM BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THOSE WHO SEEK
TO LIMIT RESTRICT AND DEPRIVE
INDIVIDUALS METONYMY OR SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. I AM
PROUD TO BE A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH CONTINUES TO WORK TOWARDS
EXPANDING ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE CARE. I'M ALSO
INCREDIBLY PROUD TO BE A CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOCUSED ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. THE FIRST
OF ITS KIND IN THE NATION AND
WHEN THEY CONTINUES TO DO WORK
TO CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S WORK
TO BE REFLECTIVE HEALTHCARE
STATE FOR ALL. AND I LAST LIKE
MANY HEARING WE BEGAN THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE
LANDSCAPE OF ACCESS. TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
WOMEN AND MEN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HEARD ABOUT THE GROWING
VOID AND BARRIERS TO CARE.
THOSE BARRIERS RANGED FROM
ACCESS FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES.
GROWING SECURITY CONCERNS
FEDERAL POLICIES THAT SEEKS TO
DECIMATE COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS CULTURAL
COMPETENCY. ONE AREA WE
DISCUSSED IN THAT HEARING. WAS
IT IMPACTED IN I LIVE CARE WE
ARE HAVING ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
OUR HEARING TODAY INTENDS TO
TAKE A DEEPER DIVE INTO THIS
ISSUE AND PRODUCE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SCOPE AND IMPACT OF
THESE DENIALS. SPECIFICALLY WE
WILL LOOK AT BARRIERS TO CARE
THAT HAVE RESULTED FROM A
LEGEND BASED HEALTH CARE
REFUSALS. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WE'VE GATHERED AN INCREDIBLE
GROUP OF EXPERT PANELISTS AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL IN
ADVANCE FOR BEING HERE TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION WITH BASS.
THEY WILL PROVIDE US WITH
INFORMATION ON THE CURRENT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND HOW RELIGIOUS
BASED HEALTH CARE FUELS ARE
IMPACTING CALIFORNIANS.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR OWN
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL HHS ISSUED
SWEEPING REGULATIONS. CREATED
TO. CREATE AND CREATED A
SPECIAL ENFORCEMENT OFTEN JUST
TO PROTECT. THE ABILITY OF
INSTITUTIONS AND INDIVIDUALS TO
DENY CARE BASED ON RELIGION.
THIS REFUSAL OF CARE RULE DOES
NOTHING TO PROTECT PATIENT
HEALTH CARE AND IS DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN. REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTHCARE IN LGBTQ INDIVIDUALS.
ALREADY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS USE THIS RULE
TO GO AFTER CALIFORNIA
THREATENING OUR STATE TO TAKE
AWAY FEDERAL HEALTH CARE
FUNDING BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
ABORTION AS BASIC HEALTH CARE.
WE ARE STANDING STRONG AND
TRYING TO PROTECT OUR EXISTING
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE AND OUR
LAWS IN CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
PATIENTS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL EXAMINE
WITH THE EXPANDING ROLE OF
RELIGIOUSLY RESTRICTIVE
HOSPITALS MEAN FOR THOSE
SEEKING KAREN CALIFORNIA. WELL
THESE HOSPITALS DO SOME
INCREDIBLE WORK WE CAN'T IGNORE
WHAT THEIR PREVALENCE IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM MEANS FOR
COMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE JOINED US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND ASK
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY OPENING
REMARKS. SO LET ME FIRST START
BY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING AND FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND I WANT TO SEND EARLY THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR PANELISTS WHO
ARE GOING TO HELP EDUCATE US.
ON THE TOPIC OF TODAY. ARE AS I
THINK MANY OF US HAVE DISCUSSED
HERE THE LEGISLATURE. ENSURING
THAT ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO THOROUGH
COMPREHENSIVE AND ACCURATE
HEALTH CARE. SHOULD BE
CONTROVERSIAL BUT SADLY IT IS.
I CERTAINLY EXPERIENCED THIS
WHEN OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN I AUTHORED THE
REPRODUCTIVE FACT ACT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN- WHERE WE WERE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE. HUNDREDS OF FAKE HEALTH
CENTERS AROUND THE STATE. THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING WOMEN WITH
VERY MISLEADING AND INACCURATE
CARE- TODAY WE'RE DISCUSSING
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETHING QUITE
SIMILAR. AND THE FACT IN THE
REALITY THAT THERE ARE
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND
HEALTH PROVIDERS. THAT ARE
RESTRICTING AND LIMITING ACCESS
TO VERY NECESSARY. AND
COMPREHENSIVE CARE. BOB RIDLEY
ON A RELIGIOUS BASE THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO
I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR A LOT
OF GOOD. TO WHAT WE TO DO TO
MOVE FOR. I WANT TO MENTION THE
YEAR. ALONG WITH OTHERS I GOING
TO BE. FOR A BUDGET ASK A ONE
TIME BUDGET ASKED TO ENSURE
THAT MEDICAL RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE AND TRANS GENDER
HEALTHCARE TRAINING IN PART
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE OPTED OUT.
DUE TO RELIGIOUS OR MORAL
OBJECTIONS AND UP OR OTHER
RESTRICTIONS RELATED TO FEDERAL
FUNDING- THIS IS CARE THAT IS
NOT- AS WIDELY AVAILABLE AS IT
NEEDS TO BE BUT THERE'S JUST SO
MANY ASPECTS TO- TO THIS ISSUE
AND I JUST. WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND LOOKING FOR THE WORKING
WITH THE MADAM CHAIR AND OTHERS
AND- HOW WE ADDRESS THIS. YEAR
WHENEVER. JUST FOR APPRECIATION
NINETY CONNORS AND- BE INCLUDE
AND LOOK FOR THE TEST FROM OUR-
THAT THIS MORNING. THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL WELCOME OUR FIRST
PANEL. AND RELIGION BASED HOW
FUSE IN THE FED AND STATE KIND.
WEMELANIE FOR HIS RAINY THIS.
SYSTEM TO THE- TURN GENERAL THE
CALIFORNIA. OF JUSTICE. MICHELE
GOODWIN DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR BIOTECHNOLOGY IN GLOBAL
HEALTH POLICY AT THE UC IRVINE
SCHOOL OF LAW. AND MAGGIE CROWD
CHIEF LEGAL COUNSEL FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. YOUR WOULDN'T MIND
COMING UP IN JOINING US. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US IN MELANIE
WILL START WITH YOU IF YOU'RE
SMOKING REMARKS. COURSE. A GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU BROUGHT ME TO TESTIFY
FOR THE SELECT COMMITTEE- I
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS A TRUE GENERAL'S A
SENIOR ADVISER IN SPECIAL
ASSISTANT- WELL AND I
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS SENIOR
COUNSEL THE WOMEN'S POLICY. THE
SENATE EDUCATION LABOR AND-
PENSIONS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS-
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THE
UNITED STATES SENATE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING SAFE AND
LEGAL ABORTION IS CRITICAL AND
I'M HONORED TO SPEAK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ON THIS-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ABOUT
BARRIERS TO CARE. CITY
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG PRIORITIZE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
FRAME THAT WORKS TO BALANCE
ACCESS TO CARE IMPATIENCE RATES
WITH CONSCIOUS PROTECTIONS.
ARMY CALIFORNIA THIS HAS MEANT
YOU KNOW THE STATE HAS PASSED
SEVERAL LAWS- IN EFFECT TO
PROTECT ACCESS TO ABORTION
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE CONTRACEPTIVES A PRACTICE
LAW THE REPRODUCTIVE PRIVACY.
THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY ACT
EXITS EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTIVES-
AND ALSO RELIGIOUS CONSCIENCE
LIES RIGHT WHICH ALLOW FOR THAT
NO PLAYER SUMMER THIS. THE
PROJECT IN A- EMPLOYER HAS
FILED A WRITTEN STATEMENT. CAN
YOU MORE ETHICAL REAL. BASIS
FOR IF YOU PROJECT WHICH HAS A
PAY. BUT BALANCING THE NEEDS
THE PATIENT THAT THE OF CARE IS
A INTER WITH AND THAT THERE ARE
IN FROM EMERGENCY MISC. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN AS THAT WILL HAD
DISCUSSED THE HAVE BEEN A ARRAY
OF A- ON REPEAT HEALTH THERE
HAVE LONG BEEN RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION THE CHURCH SNOW AND-
ON THIS FROM BECAUSE IT'S A FOR
YOU. GET IN SO OF THIS THE
FEDERAL HAS PRIOR TO USING REAL
CON FLY TO HARM AND I CARE I
MADE SECOND TWENTY NIGHTS
DIMINISH FOR. RULE TO EXPAND
SCOPE OF CON SAT ALLOWING
VIRTUALLY ANYONE OF IN THE
PROVISION OF CARE DENY HEALTH
CARE REFUSE BY SERVICE.
INCLUDING WITH IN LD IN THE- I
ALLOW OUR OF SUCH TO QUE WOULD
BECOME. TO IN STATE LAW IT'S A
RULE THAT AGAIN TARGET TO SET A
CAL IN IN A VERY TARGETED WAY.
FOR THE ROLE WOULD HAVE CREATED
IT CAN. ABOUT THE HEALTH CARE
RIGHTS FEDERALLY AND HEADED
CARE. SUCH AS MEDICAID MEDICARE
WILL DISCOURAGING PROVIDERS
FROM OFFERING SAFE LEGAL
MEDICAL CARE FOR PATIENTS. THE
RULE DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
JUSTIFICATION NOTICE- REFERRAL
BE GIVEN TO THE PATIENT WHO IS
THE NIGHT CARE OR TO AN
EMPLOYER WHO MUST NOW NAVIGATE
THESE ACCOMMODATIONS IN
REFUSALS- AND THEIR NO
EXCEPTIONS FOR EMERGENCY. BIO
LAWS PAULA RULE ITSELF CAN. AND
OBJECTING ANNUAL DRIVER. COULD
ABANDON A WOMAN BLEEDING TO
DEATH FROM AN ECTOPIC. AND THAT
WOULD BE PERMISSIBLE UNDER THE
ROLE. THE REAL PERPETUATES
WIDESPREAD DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY FACE OBSTACLES TO
OBTAINING CARE. INTERFERING
WITH CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
STATES MISSIONS TO OFFER
QUALITY CARE TO PATIENTS TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WELFARE ENSURE CONTINUED ACCESS
FOR BLOOM OF OUR POPULATIONS.
THE RULE ALSO TARGET TO SAY THE
CALIFORNIA IT'S POLICY GOALS
AND PRIORITIES THREATENING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. AS A
RESULT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OVER THIS
ROLE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE AND
SUCCESSFULLY ARGUED IT WAS
UNLAWFULLY CREATED STOPPING THE
ROLE FROM GOING INTO A FACT.
THE COURT AGREED THE ROLE WAS
IN CONFLICT WITH UNDERLYING
STATUTES QUOTE THE BALLOT
STRUCK BY CAR CONGRESS AND
HARMONIZING PROTECTION OF
CONSCIOUS OBJECTIONS VIS A VIS
THE UNDER UP ON INTERRUPTED
FLOW OF THE HEALTH. TO
AMERICANS BUT WE ALL KNOW TOO
WELL THAT THIS RULE IS PART OF
A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO USE
FEDERAL RULES TO DESTROY ACCESS
TO CARE FOR WOMEN IN LGBT Q.
INDIVIDUALS. USING HEALTH CARE
AS A WEAPON. WE HAVE SEEN THIS
IN OTHER CASES LIKE THE BIRTH
CONTROL CASE WITH
ADMINISTRATION CREATED NOT ONE
BUT TWO RULES FOR A MORAL AND A
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION TO DENY
BIRTH CONTROL TO WOMEN- TITLE
TEN WHICH MY COLLEAGUE TALK OUR
NATION FAMILY. PROGRAM MEDICAL
PRIVACY BE GAGGED AND COUNTLESS
OTHERS ENSURING ACCESS REAP
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING SAFE
LEGAL ABORTION IS A PRIORITY
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE HAS AN INTEREST IN
ENSURING ALL ALL HEALTH CARE IS
IT. THOSE FIRST. TAKES VERY
SERIOUSLY AND THAT'S WHY HE'S
BEEN SO AGGRESSIVELY DEFENDING
HEALTH CARE IN LGBT CARE UNDER
THIS CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS LSO
CREATED OTHER WAYS TO PROTECT
ACCESS TO CARE ONE SUCH TOOLS
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S AUTHORITY
UNDER THE CORPORATIONS CODE.
FIFTY NINE FOURTEEN THREE FIFTY
NINE TWENTY SIX ENSURE
AVAILABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
OF SERVICES FOR ALL NONPROFIT
HEALTH CARE TRANSACTIONS.
INCLUDING NONPROFIT HEALTH
HOSPITALS. UNDER THE STAFF
THEATER GENERAL PUBLIC MEETINGS
AND HOSPITAL AFFILIATIONS
LEASES SALES EXCHANGES- THAT
THE PART OF THIS PROCESS AS WE
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT EXPERT THAT
CONDUCTS THE REVIEW OF THE
COMMUNITY AVAILABILITY
ACCESSIBILITY PURPOSES AND HOW
THIS WHOLE. MERGER IMPACTS
THOSE THOSE SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY THE PUBLIC INCLUDING
THAT AFFECTED COMMUNITY IS
ENCOURAGED. TO PARTICIPATE IN
THESE MEETINGS AND ALSO IN AND
IS ALLOWED TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
COMMENTS ON THE CHANCE. THE
TRADER TAKES YOU COMMENTS
EXPERT NOW CAN THE MEXICAN SO
EITHER NINE THE- BECAUSE IT'S
NOT IN THE BEST A OF THE CAN.
OR THE CONDITION OR WITHIN
REQUIRE. THE PART OF WITH THE
SALE MERGER LIKE CHARITY CARE
THINGS LIKE MAKING SURE THERE'S
NOT. SERVICE THINGS LIKE ME TO
THE THREE HEALTH CARE. FOR MEN
YEARS THESE CONDITIONS PRIOR
ACTS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
LONG BEFORE WE MY BOSS. WAS AN
OFF. THAT WE MADE VERY CLEAR
THAT REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AS A
PRIORITY. IN ADDITION WHEN THIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL TOOK OFFICE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HE
CREATED A NEW OFFICE CALLED THE
HEALTH CARE RIGHTS AN ACCESS
SECTION WHICH WILL ALSO LOOK TO
ENSURE- IN THESE NONPROFIT
HEALTH CARE TRANSACTIONS THAT
THERE IS ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES AND THAT WE'RE
NOT PROVIDING ACCESS AND
AVAILABILITY OF CARE. I'M A FEW
KEY KEY EXAMPLES OF THESE
MERGERS AFFILIATIONS
ACQUISITIONS- IS ONE THE
DIGNITY CATHOLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVES MERGER THIS WAS
IMPORTANT TO- THE COMMUNITY AND
ONE THAT MANY ADVOCATES MANY OF
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM TODAY
WEIGHED IN HEAVILY ON- PATIENT
GROUPS OTHERS WAIT AND WAS
ABOUT WE MAINTAIN WOMEN'S
HEALTH CARE SERVICES I'M CHANGE
FOR FIVE YEARS- IN SPITE OF THE
FACT THAT IT WAS A SECULAR.
TRANSACTION I'M ANY SIXTY TEN
WE A CLEAR. THAT THE DIGNITY IN
AND CATHOLIC AND MUST KNOW THE
GENERAL'S OFFICE AT FORTY DAYS
IN ADVANCE. BEFORE YOU READ OR
INTO IN A HEALTH SERVICES. AND
THEN. IN EXPERT TO IT WHETHER
REDUCTION DISCONTINUATION AND
IS IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
CAN. THERE WAS ALSO THE DELAY
NO MAY CENTER TRANSACTION
WITHOUT. WE'RE WE ASK VERY VERY
QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW AT
WOMEN'S HEALTH LGBT K. WOULD
WHAT HAVE WHEN YOU HAVE AN-
PREGNANCY WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
WOMAN IS SEEKING CERTAIN TYPES
OF CONTRACEPTIVES WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN A PATIENT NEEDS.
PARTICULAR COUNSELLING
REFERRALS- AND YOU'LL SEE AN
EXHIBIT TO OF THAT TRANSACTION
WE HAD VERY SPECIFIC ANSWERS
AND RESPONSES BECAUSE HE WANTED
THERE TO BE VERY CLEAR LINES IN
TERMS OF WHAT SERVICES WERE
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE. LAST
THERE WAS THE SEAT CHAU SAID
THE PROPOSING STEPS- HEALTH
SYSTEM AB INTO LAST. SYSTEM
WHICH WAS DENIED BECAUSE IT WAS
NOT IN THE INTEREST OF THE
AVAILABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
OF HEALTH CARE SYSTEM COMMUNITY.
ON THIS WORK ANY BE A PRETTY
FOR THE GENERAL. AND WE'LL BE
WORK CLOSELY. THE ROOM ACROSS
THE DIET. WHEN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKE IT. THANK YOU. THANK SO
MUCH FOR PAINTING LANDSCAPING
FOR WORK WITH THE GENERAL. MISS
CROWE YOU HAVE OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU. I MORNING MY NAME
MAGGIE AND PRIOR TO BECOMING
FOR PARENTHOOD SHE LEGAL. CA
YEARS I WAS A- AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. FOR ABOUT
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN YEARS RIGHT
HANDLED SEXUAL ABUSE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES- THE IT MY
MESSAGE TODAY IS ABOUT- OUR
PATIENTS AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE THE
BARRIERS THAT THEY FACE. AND
HOW THE RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES
HAVE HAVE IMPACTED THOSE
CHALLENGES AND CREATED
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS- VISIT THE
POINT HERE IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AS TO
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE. HEALTH
CARE. IF OF CALIFORNIA. SEVEN
IF IN CAL THEY ALL OFFER
REGIONALLY AND TOGETHER WE
OPERATE A HUNDRED AND EIGHT
HEALTH CENTERS AROUND THE
STATE. AND SEE CLOSE TO A
MILLION PATIENTS EACH YEAR
PROVIDING PATIENTS WITH FULL
SCOPE OF SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE.
INCLUDING ABORTION. AS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS EDUCATORS
AND ADVOCATES PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS COMMITTED TO
SERVING ALL PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH CARE AND
RESPECT. WE BELIEVE THAT ALL
PEOPLE DESERVE HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE AND
COMPASSIONATE NON JUDGMENTAL
EDUCATION. AS WELL AS THE
ABILITY AND THE RE THIS IS TO
MAKE THEIR OWN HEALTHCARE
DECISIONS DIGNITY. WE BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE NO MATTER WHO
THEY ARE OR WHERE THEY LIVE
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED TO LIVE HEALTHY
LIVES. PLAN THEIR FAMILIES MEET
THEIR LIFE GOALS WITHOUT
CHAMBER JUDGMENT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE REALITY IS
THAT NOT ALL PEOPLE DO. ALONG
WITH FACING BARRIERS SUCH AS
COSTS TO TRANSPORTATION
INSURANCE CO PAYS DEDUCTIBLES
JUST TO NAME A FEW. PATIENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE ALSO
FACED WITH UNJUST LAWS STICK MY
DEEP ROOTED HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
INEQUALITIES. AND FORCE
RELIGIOUS IDEOLOGY WHEN
ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS CRITICAL
CARE. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS BEEN WORKING TO PUT UP
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
TO CARE FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS AND MANY OF WHICH ARE
GROUNDED IN RELIGIOUS IDEOLOGY.
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THREE
EXAMPLES- THAT MY COLLEAGUE HAS
ALREADY TOUCHED ON A BIT SO
FIRST OF ALL THE BIRTH CONTROL
MANDATE ROLL BACK- THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT REQUIRES
THAT EMPLOYERS PROVIDE COVERAGE
TO EMPLOYEES FOR BIRTH CONTROL
WITHOUT IMPOSING CARSHARING BUT
THE ROLL. WOULD HAVE EXEMPTED
EMPLOYERS WITH RELIGIOUS OR
MORAL OBJECTIONS FROM THIS
REQUIREMENT. SO IF EMPLOYERS
REFUSED TO PROVIDE COVERAGE TO
EMPLOYEES FOR CONTRACEPTION
BECAUSE O THEIR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS MANY PEOPLE HAVE TO PAY
OUT OF POCKET FOR CONTRACEPTION
SUFFER GAPS IN CARE AS THEY TRY
TO HUNT DOWN- ALTERNATIVE
COVERAGE OR FOR GO
CONTRACEPTION LEADING TO AN
INCREASE. IN UNINTENDED
PREGNANCIES PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE CARE THAT IS NOT
INTERRUPTED OR DENY DUE TO AN
EMPLOYER'S RELIGIOUS. BELIEFS
LEADS TO MORE POSITIVE OUTCOMES
WE'VE SEEN THIS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN- WITH OUR PATIENTS
DECREASES IN UNINTENDED
PREGNANCIES OR LONG TERM GOALS
AND CORRESPONDING. DECREASES IN
THE REST GOVERNMENT MORTALITY
OR ADVERSE CHILD HEALTH
OUTCOMES. SO THIS RULE IS
CURRENTLY JOINED BY. A LIMITED
SCOPE IN JUNCTION IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS A NATIONWIDE
INJUNCTION PENNSYLVANIA BUT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
WE'LL BE HEARING ARGUMENT ON
IT- IN APRIL I THINK APRIL
TWENTY NINTH- ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF THE TITLE TEN GAG RULE-
WHICH WHICH WE'VE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IN HERE ALREADY BUT THIS
IS WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
USED IDEOLOGY TO LIMIT. ACCESS
TO SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE OVER THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION ACCESS. LAST YEAR THE
UNETHICAL RESTRICTIONS OF THE
TITLE TEN GAGGLE FORCED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD NATIONALLY AND
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA OUT OF THE
TITLE TEN PROGRAM. AND THAT WAS
THE NATION'S ONLY DEDICATED
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
REBEL BIRTH CONTROL PROGRAM FOR
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS. WE WERE
FORCED OUT BECAUSE WE REFUSE TO
WITHHOLD CRUCIAL INFORMATION
FROM PATIENTS OF THEIR
PREGNANCY OPTION. BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR
THERE HEALTH. AND THEIR- IT'S.
A PLAN. ENTER THE HEALTH. HAD
ROUTE BE PART OF THE TITLE AND
PRO. WHICH A MILLION PAGE
HEARING AND TO THIRDS THOSE.
ACTUALLY RECEIVE. CARE AT ONE.
IT HAS A HUNDRED AND EIGHT HELL
CENTERS. PLANNED PARENTHOOD
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO BIRTH
CONTROL EXPAND STI TESTING AND
TREATMENT AND ADVANCE ACCESS IN
OTHER AREAS OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. DESPITE BEING
FORCED OUT OF THE PROGRAM WHILE
THE COURT PROCEEDINGS RAN THEIR
COURSE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES- HAVE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
AND NON JUDGMENT JUDGMENTAL BUT-
SEX CASE. WHICH ONLY NINE
CIRCUIT RECENTLY DIDN'T CHANGE
AND OF OUR ABILITY TO IN THE-
CALIFORNIA PARENTHOOD IS CAN TO
BE FORCED OUT WERE
SUPPLEMENTING THE LACK OF TITLE
TEN FUNDS. WITH OTHER FUNDING
STREAMS- BUT THE POINT THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE HERE AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND IS
THIS VERY DANGEROUS PHENOMENON
OF THE EMERGENCE OF FAKE
CLINICS WITHOUT NEXT WITHOUT
MEDICAL EXPERTISE IN THOSE
CLINICS. ARE GAINING GROUND AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO KNOWS ALL
TOO WELL AND THE EXAMPLE IN THE
TITLE TEN SPACE. IS BREA- BREA.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY CHRISTIAN
MINISTRY AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER OVER YOUR RECEIVED FEDERAL
FUNDS. ARE FROM THE GOVERNMENT
FROM TITLE TEN. AND THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. YOU KNOW REALLY
LIEU LEGITIMIZING RELIGIOUS
IDEOLOGY WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
SPACE SO THEY ARE A CHRISTIAN
BASED CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTER
THAT VETS ALL THEIR EMPLOYEES
TO ENSURE THAT. IT IS HIRING-
SUFFICIENTLY CHRISTIAN AND
HE'S- AND THERE'S EVEN A
QUESTION ON THEIR INTAKE FORMS-
ASKING PATIENTS ABOUT THEIR OWN
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. ALTHOUGH A
RE IT CLAIMS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE OF IS NOT FROM
ABORTION OR MAKE ABORTION
REFERRALS. AND DOES NOT PROVIDE
ANY HORMONAL BIRTH CONTROL
INSTEAD PROMOTING NATURAL
FAMILY PLANNING. SEEKING
CONTROL OR OF. MIGHT MIGHT GO
TO A REAL BELIEVING THAT IT
OFFERS THE SERVICES THAT THEY
SEEK. IF YOU IF YOU LOOK ON THE
INTERNET YOU CAN EASILY- BE
DIRECTED TO A RIO WHEN GOOGLING
SOMETHING LIKE BIRTH CONTROL OR
ABORTION- BUT INSTEAD YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TREATED BY PEOPLE
WHO WERE WHO REFUSED TO PROVIDE
THOSE SIR. AS BECAUSE THEIR OWN
WILL FULLY. AND PATIENTS MAY
ALSO BE CURT TO GET TREATMENT
THAT IS INEFFECTIVE OR EVEN
DANGEROUS THEIR HEALTH. FOR
EXAMPLE- OVER YET TOUTED ITS
USE OF THE ABORTION REVERSAL
PILL AND ON. SAID THAT IS. THAT
YOU HAD HALL A STUDY IT. DOES
CURVES AS AN OBSTACLE BUT A
BARRIER BECAUSE PAGE ARE TO IN
THIS. FROM THE CARE THEY NEED.
AND IF THEY LEAVE OR HERE TO
SEE ANOTHER PRO LIKE PLAN
PARENTHOOD THEIR DELAY. IN
RECEIVING THE CARE THEY NEED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS REAL
HAS CHEN MY IS A RELIGIOUS
IDEOLOGY THAT OVER YET ESPOUSES
BY GRANTING THEM TITLE TEN
FUNDING. ORANGE COUNTY HAS ALSO
GIVEN LEGITIMACY TO OVER YEAH
BY AWARDING A REAL MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR ABSTINENCE ONLY EDUCATION
MONEY THAT A PRE. EVENT AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD. THE FINAL
EXAMPLE- THAT I WANTED THAT I
WANT TO GIVE HERE THAT. MY
COLLEAGUES ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT- I'M IS A FEDERAL PERMIT
YOU RELIGIOUS IDEOLOGY TO
CONSTRUCT. ACT I'M AS- THAT
REFUSAL AT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THOSE IN THE MEDICAL FIELD TO
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON THEIR OWN
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS THE REFUSAL
ROLE IS DANGEROUS TO PATIENTS A
PERSON'S HEALTH CARE SHOULD NOT
BE GOVERNED BY THE PERSON
HEALTHCARE SHOULD BE GOVERNED
BY MEDICAL NEED NOT BY THE
RELIGIOUS VIEW POINTS OF A
PHARMACIST- HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATOR A DOCTOR THE RULE
WOULD HAVE ALLOWED DOCTORS AND
OTHER HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO
REFUSE TO TREAT OR HELP
PATIENTS BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS WHICH
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST PATIENTS
AND NICE PEOPLE HEALTHCARE.
LGBT Q. PEOPLE WHO ALREADY FACE
SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING HEALTHCARE COULD BE
DENIED POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING
HEALTHCARE THERE WOULD ALSO
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
BARRIERS TO ACT. FINLEY
ABORTION. RULE AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW REALLY ENTER ABOVE THE HOW
AND OF PATIENTS IN DEFIANCE OF
FUNDAMENTAL MEDICAL ETHICS
JEOPARDIZES PATIENTS ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE CARE SO AS YOU
CAN SEE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ATTACKS UPON HEALTHCARE HAVE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN BEEN DRIVEN
BY RELIGIOUS IDEOLOGY THAT
PURPOSELY CONSTRUCTS BARRIERS
TO CARE BUT NO THIS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA AND MANY OTHER
POSITIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
COMMITTED TO EXPANDING NOT
BANNING ACCESS TO CRITICAL
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE BY BREAKING ON THESE VERY
TO CARE. WE SPONSORED A BILL BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM LONGER TO
ENSURE THAT PROVIDERS ARE
TRAINED ON IMPLICIT BIAS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BREAKING DOWN
BARRIERS TO CARE FOR THE MOST
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PAGE ARE IN FACT 90% AT OR
BELOW 2100% OF THE FEDERAL
ALREADY LINED WE SERVE A
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION
IMMIGRANTS REGARDLESS OF STATUS
MIGRANT WORKERS THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
PATIENTS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
SKILLS LBT LGBT Q. PEOPLE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD ALSO PROVIDE
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
TO FURTHER BREAK DOWN BARRIERS
TO CARE OUR SERVICES INCLUDE
EDUCATION IN A SLING ON SEXUAL
AND REPRINT HEALTH GENDERS
BIRTH CONTROL INCLUDE EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTION TESTING AND MEN
OF SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS AND H. I. V. THE
FILM ALSO PROVIDE. STING
PURPOSES SINCE ANSWERED IS AS.
SERVICES OFFERED TO REACH
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND EVEN
THOSE FROM OTHER STATES AND TO
MEET PATIENTS WHERE THEY ARE.
BUT ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
SHOULDN'T DEPEND ON YOUR ZIP
CODE OUR RIGHTS ARE FREEDOMS
AND OUR HEALTH CARE SHOULD
DEPEND ON WHERE WE LIVE. HOW
MUCH MONEY WE HAVE OR WHAT
RELIGION ARE DOCTOR IS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS CRAWFORD
THAT INSIGHT. I'M AND NOW WE
WILL ASK MISS GOOD ONE IF SHE
HAS ANY OPENING REMARKS S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH. IT IS A PLEASURE AND
HONOR TO BE WITH YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS MICHELLE. ROGER GOOD
WHEN I AM A CHANCELLOR'S
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE WHERE I
DIRECT THE CENTER FOR
BIOTECHNOLOGY. AND GLOBAL
HEALTH POLICY. THE PRE TO WRITE
MY REMARKS IS THAT PRESERVING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PROTECTING
IT IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE. THE
US LEADS THE DEVELOPED WORLD IN
THE RATE OF MATERNAL MORTALITY.
IF YOU GO TO THE C. I. A.'S
WEBSITE THAT'S THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES WEBSITE
YOU'D SEE THAT IT'S SAFER FOR A
WOMAN A- BIRTH IN BOSNIA OR SO
YOUR RATE YEAH. THE YOU STATES
BECAUSE THE RISK THAT EVEN IN
STATES THAT IS IN THOSE. WE
LACK FAR ABOUT. TREES HE WOULD
CONSIDER NOT BE OUR PEER GROUP
THE THEY COUNTRY. ARE THAT WAY.
OTHER TIME HAVE CALLED. BIRD
WERE THERE CALLED PART OF OUR
DEVELOPING SOUTH. BUT MEN DOT
IN OUR COUNTRY I AT LEARNING
RATES WOMEN. BLACK MEN IN
PARTICULAR THEIR RATE MATERNAL.
IS ABOUT TIME THAT OF WHITE
WOMEN EVEN MORE DRAMATIC
INSTEAD LIKE LOUISE. AND
MISSISSIPPI AND OUR- BUT IT'S
NOT JUST THE RATES OF DEATH
THAT AND- IN THAT NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO. THE UNITED STATES
LEADS IT'S A GLOBAL PEERS AND
THE RATES OF STDS AND SYPHILIS
IN AND WANTED UP. SEE IN FACT
IS THIS A CD. THAT THE GO I. OR
IT. NOT I WE HAD A SOMETHING WE
HAD OUT TO THE FULLEST IN OUR
COUNTRY INCLUDING CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS WILL NOW IT'S BACK AND
EVEN AT GREATER RATES IN
CALIFORNIA THAN WHAT WE WOULD
HAVE LIKED. AND IRONICALLY.
WITH THE ATTACKS ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH INCLUDING I
EDUCATION AT SCHOOLS WHICH
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT. AND
INCLUDING A DIRECT SERVICES
TITLE TEN AND MORE. A WOMAN IS
FOURTEEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
DIE BY CARRYING A PREGNANCY TO
TERM IN THE UNITED STATES THAN
SHE IS BY TERMINATING THAT
PREGNANCY. LET ME CONCLUDE MY
PREAMBLE BEFORE I GET INTO MY
MAIN- REMARKS BY JUST STATING
THE FOLLOWING IT WAS GEORGE H.
W. BUSH WHO SHEPHERDED TITLE
TEN. THROUGH CONGRESS AND IT
WAS RICHARD NIXON WHO SIGNED
THAT LEGISLATION INTO LAW. AND
ONE INTERVIEWED BOTH SET THIS
WAS BSIC PUBLIC HEALTH AND
BASIC COMMON SENSE IT'S A SHAME
BUT NOW THERE'S BEEN SUCH A
DRAMATIC ATTACK AND- IN A
PILLAGING OF THE RESOURCES THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN. IN
THAT PROGRAM. I'M A LAW
PROFESSOR AND I AM A
BIOETHICIST- I'M- MORE OVER THE
CORE AREA OF MY SCHOLARSHIP AND
TEACHING OUR HEALTH LAW
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW ON TORT LAW.
IN ADDITION TO MY APPOINTMENT
AS A CHANCE WHICH PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE I DIRECT THE CENTER FOR
BIOTECHNOLOGY IN GLOBAL HEALTH
POLICY AS I MENTIONED BEFORE.
BY FURTHER WAY OF BACKGROUND
I'M AN ELECTED MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN LAW INSTITUTE. AND THE
HASTINGS CENTER WHICH IS AN
INDEPENDENT NONPARTISAN
RESEARCH INSTITUTE WHICH WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING
THE FIELD F BIOETHICS. FINALLY
I BEGAN MY LAW TEACHING CAREER
AT A CATHOLIC AFFILIATED LAW
SCHOOL WHERE I ALSO DIRECTED
IT'S HEALTH WHAT PROGRAM AND I
GRADUATED FROM A CATHOLIC LAW
SCHOOL I AM DEEPLY FAMILIAR
WITH THE CHURCH IT'S ACTUALLY
VALID. AND SKETCHING SO. FROM
THE OUTSIDE I WISH TO MAKE.
CLEAR THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND- AFFILIATIONS
WHICH IMPEDE RESTRICT OR HINDER
THE CARE OF YOU SEE STUDENTS
FACULTY OR STAFF. THAT THEY
RECEIVED BASED ON RELIGIOUS
DOCTRINE VIOLATE STATE AND
FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONAL LAW AS
WELL AS SPECIFIC CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATION THAT FOR BID. THE
IMPOSITION OF RELIGIOUS
DOCTRINE ON YOU SEE STUDENT
FACULTY OR STAFF STATE AND
FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONAL LAW ALSO
PROHIBITS UC AND MEDICAL
INSTITUTIONS FOR STRIPPING.
IMPEDING OR BUYING HERE ON THE
BAY FOR LIVE DOCTRINE. THE
ACTIONS THAT THEY CAN SEND THE
PEACE STAMP DATE QUOTE. NUMBERS
AND HEART IN THE PAST. HERE'S
THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE NINE
SECTION NINE SUB PART II.
HOWEVER ONE NEED NOT SCOUR THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTION TO LOCATE
THIS IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE IT IS
PROMINENTLY FEATURED ON THE
WEBSITE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REGENTS. OF THE MANY
DOCUMENTS THAT MAY BE PROVIDED
TO YOU AND THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ACCESS TO AFTER THE WORKING
GROUP WHICH WAS APPOINTED RIGHT
UP PRESIDENT OF POLITICS ON A-
ESTABLISHMENT DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE THAT ARE PART OF THAT
PACKAGE. YOU WILL SEE THAT THIS
PRINCIPLED STANDS OUT BUT I
URGE A DEEPER READING OF THE
ENTIRE ARTICLE NINE IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION FROM
WHICH THIS IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE
EMERGES. AS IT GRUNDS NOT ONLY
THAT PRINCIPLE BUT ALSO PLACES
AND LARGER CONTEXT. THE RIGHTS
AND LIBERTIES OF THE PEOPLE AND
FOR THE PROMOTION OF LECTURE.
CONTENT AND MORE IMPROVEMENT.
THIS BY A CLOSE READING OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTION
ARTICLE NINE SECTION THIRTEEN
SUBPART F. SORRY TO GET INTO
SUCH IMPORTANT DETAIL BUT I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I
GIVEN WHAT IS AT STAKE. BECAUSE
IT ALSO SPECIFY QUOTE THE
UNIVERSITY SHALL BE ENTIRELY
INDEPENDENT OF ALL POLITICAL
AND SECTARIAN INFLUENCE AND
KEPT FREE THERE FROM IN THE
APPOINTMENT OF ITS REGIONS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION. IT'S A
FIGURES. THE CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTIONAL FRAMERS WERE
CLEAR ABOUT THE SEPARATION OF
RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE FROM ITS
EDUCATIONAL AFFAIRS THROUGHOUT
ARTICLE NINE IT SPEAKS TO THIS
NOR SHALL ANY SECTARIAN OR
DENOMINATIONAL DOCTRINE BE
TAUGHT. OR INSTRUCTION THERE ON
PERMITTED DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY IN ANY OF THE COMMON
SCHOOLS OF THIS STATE THIS
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION ARTICLE
NINE SECTION EIGHT. THE
CONSTITUTIONAL FRAMERS SOUGHT
TO PROTECT RELIGIOUS MINORITIES
FROM DISCRIMINATION BUT VERY
CLEAR THAT NEITHER COMMON
SCHOOLS NOR UNIVERSITIES WOULD
BE IN WHAT. OR DICTATED TO BITE
RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE SO WHAT IS
AT STAKE. HERE ARE AT STAKE END
OF CONCERN THE PRESENT MATTER
OUR CONTRACTS SIGNED BY THE UC
EXECUTIVES THAT VIOLATE THE
IMPORTANT CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES THAT I JUST STATED
ABOVE. THE CONTRACTS OF
CONCERN- WHICH I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW OUR
PRIMARILY INTRODUCED TO WITH
CATHOLIC AFFILIATED MEDICAL
PROVIDERS HERE I'LL SINGLE OUT
CATHOLIC AFFILIATIONS BECAUSE
THEY EXPLICITLY DEMAND
CONDITIONS OF THE YOU SEE THAT
VIOLATE. CONSTITUTIONAL LAW AND
THUS IMPERMISSIBLE EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE MANY ORGANIZATIONS
WITH WHICH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AFFILIATES AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT. A CALF
HOSPITALS DO SERVE THE POOR AND
THAT IS WONDERFUL THAT THEY DO
THAT AND THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
INVESTED- IN DOING THAT BUT
THAT'S NOT THE QUESTION THAT WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US TODAY. AND
WHILE I UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
CONTRACTS ARE BEING NEGOTIATED
AT THE PRESENT RENEGOTIATED AT
THE PRESENT THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE INTERRED INTO OBLIGATING
AND BINDING YOU SEE STUDENTS
FACULTY AND EMPLOYEES TO FOLLOW
RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE IS DEEPLY
DISCONCERTING. AND A VIOLATION
OF LAW. TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS AT STAKE AND WHY THE
PERCEPTION THAT THE
AFFILIATIONS WILL NOT.
COMPROMISE CONSTITUTIONAL
VALUES IS ON FOUND IT I POINT
YOU TO THE ETHICAL AND
RELIGIOUS RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES
FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE DOCUMENT THAT
LOOKS LIKE THIS ONE WHICH X.
ENDS UPON PAGE BY PAGE IS IT'S-
WRITTEN BY THE UNITED STATES
CONFERENCE OF CATHOLIC. AT THIS
IS THE SIXTH XIN. OUTLINES
WHAT- THE RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES
ARE WHAT THE CHURCH WILL LET
WILL NOT ATTACK. THANK YOU WAS
DEVELOPED BY. NINE ON. OF YOUR
STATES CA OF BISHOPS THE U. S.
C. C. B. AND APPROVED BY THE U.
S. C. C. B. AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AT ITS PLENARY
ASSEMBLY. THIS DOCUMENT SERVES
AS THE CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE IN
IT SERVES AS THE THEOLOGICAL
BASIS FOR THE CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE MINISTRY. THEIR WORD TO
DEFINE HER CONDITIONS UNDER
WHICH CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
INSTITUTIONS WILL ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS. THE A RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES OTHER RISE REFERRED
TO AS E. R. D.'S GUIDE CATHOLIC
MEDICAL CARE. SIMPLY PUT THE E.
R. D.'S DICTATE ALL
ARRANGEMENTS COLLABORATIONS IN
CONTRACTS WITH AFFILIATES SUCH
AS THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM THE LANGUAGE IS
UNEQUIVOCAL EXPLICIT AND REALLY
HARD TO MISS THE BISHOPS RIGHT
QUOTE THE CATHOLIC PARTY IN A
COLLABORATIVE ARRANGEMENT HAS
THE RESPONSES BE TO ASSESS
PERIODICALLY WHETHER THE
BINDING AGREEMENT IS BEING
OBSERVED AND IMPLEMENTED IN A
WAY THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
NATURAL MORAL LAW. CATHOLIC
TEACHING AND CAMPAñA NOT
CALIFORNIA LAW. THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH MAY DICTATE ITS OWN
TEACHINGS AND THEOLOGICAL
PHILOSOPHIES BUT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA MUST NOT BE RULED
NOR GOVERNED BY THEM. EQUALLY
THE UC MUST NOT IN FORCE
CATHOLIC TEACHING. HOWEVER THE
E. R. D.'S LEAVE LITTLE ROOM
FOR SPECULATION OR DOUBT THAT
THAT IS THE CATHOLIC CHURCH'S
VALUES PRINCIPLES AND
DIRECTIVES THAT WILL GOVERN ALL
CONTRACTS ENTERED INTO. FOR
EXAMPLE V. E. R. D. FURTHER
STATE QUOTE BEFORE AFFILIATING
WITH A HEALTH CARE INTO T. THAT
PERMITS IMMORAL PROCEDURES.
LIKE INSTITUTION MUST ENSURE
THAT IN THERE IT'S
ADMINISTRATORS NOR ITS
EMPLOYEES WILL MANAGE CARRY OUT
ASSIST IN CARRYING OUT MAKE ITS
THE LADY'S AVAILABLE FOR MAKE
REFERRALS FOR OR BENEFIT FROM
THE REVENUE GENERATED BY
IMMORAL PROCEDURES. HERE DO YOU
ARE ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
CATHOLIC RELIGIOUS VALUE WILL
DICTATE ALL TERMS AND ALL
MEDICAL AFFILIATIONS THAT IS
QUOTE IN ANY TIME ELABORATION
WHAT EVER COMES UNDER THE
CONTROL OF THE CATHOLIC IT TO
XIN WHETHER ACQUISITION. I IT'S
WARM IN A MEANT MUST BE OPERATE
IN FOR ACCORD WITH THE MORAL
TEACHINGS OF THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH INCLUDING THESE
DIRECTIVES. EVEN THOUGH SOME
MEDICAL EXECUTIVES IN THE UC
MIGHT BELIEVE THEIR INFORMAL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS QUOTE OVER
RIDE THE CONTRACTS THEY WOULD
BE MISTAKEN. IN THE CONTRACT
THAT I HAVE REVIEWED DURING MY
TIME IN WORKING ON A WORKING
GROUP APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
THE POLITBURO THE EXPENSE WILL
EXPLICITLY DRAW UPON THAT THIS
TYPE OF LANGUAGE IN THE
CONTRACT WITH UC IRVINE THE
AFFILIATION AGREEMENT WITH ST
JOSEPH'S HOSPITAL OF ORANGE
STATES C<c.cyan>. PATIENT CARE</c>
PURSUANT TO SECTION SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ONE THREE OF TITLE TWENTY
TWO SCHOOL UNDERSTANDS AND
AGREES THAT HOSPITAL WITH ITS
MEDICAL STAFF RETAINS
PROFESSIONAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SERVICES
RENDERED TO HOSPITAL PATIENT.
FURTHER SCHOOL SHALL CONDUCT
ITS ACTIVITIES AND PROVIDING
SERVICES HERE UP HERE UNDER
CONSISTENT WITH HOSPITAL
PHILOSOPHY HOSPITAL PHILOSOPHY
PHILOSOPHY MEANING CATHOLIC
CHURCH PHILOSOPHY. AND VALUES
AND THE ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH
SERVICES. SIMILARLY THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN CONTRACT
BETWEEN DIGNITY HEALTH AND THE
REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
DEMANDS QUOTE STUDENTS AND
INSTRUCTORS SHALL COMPLY WITH
THE STATEMENT OF COMMON VALUES
AS ADOPTED BY DIGNITY. AND IF
FACILITY IS CATHOLIC SPONSORED
WITH THE ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES FOR THE CATHOLIC
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS ADOPTED
BY THE UNITED STATES CONFERENCE
OF CATHOLIC. BISHOPS
PROBLEMATICALLY UC STUDENTS
WERE ALSO MADE TO SIGN SUCH
CONTRACTS OBLIGATING THEM
THAT'S LEE QUOTE. IT IS
UNDERSTOOD AND AGREED THAT
HOSPITAL AS A DIVISION OF
DIGNITY HEALTH. OPERATES AS AN
EXTENSION OF THE RELIGIOUS
WORKS OF THE DIGNITY HEALTH
RELIGIOUS SPONSORS. FOR IT IS
UNDERSTOOD AND AGREED THAT THE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES OF
HOSPITAL SHALL CONFORM TO THE
PRINCIPLES INHERENT IN THE
ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE'S SAYS INCORPORATED. BOB
REFERENCE SO NOT ONLY STUDENTS
BEING OBLIGATED TO FOLLOW VIS
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS BUT ALSO MEDICAL
PROVIDERS ALSO BEING FORCED TO
FOLLOW THESE IN THE CONTRACTS
THAT WERE SIGNED. FOR STUDENTS
THE PRESSURE CO WORST OR FORCED
TO SIGN SUCH AGREEMENTS WHICH
CONFLICT WITH THEIR VALUES THEY
MIGHT FEEL INTIMIDATED OR
PERCEIVED BINDING SUCH
CONTRACTS AS A CONDITION OF
THEIR EDUCATION THEY MIGHT
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO PRACTICE E. R. D.
DICTATED MEDICINE AS PART OF
THEIR YOU SEE EDUCATION. WE OF
CONCERN THEN ARE THE TERMS TO
WHICH YOU FACULTY STUDENTS AND
STAFF ARE HELD AS PATIENT OR
PROVIDERS FOR EXAMPLE E. R. D.
SEVENTY STATES QUOTE. CATHOLIC
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
NOT PERMITTED TO ENGAGE IN%
IMMEDIATE MATERIAL COOPERATION
IN ACTIONS ARE INTRINSICALLY
IMMORAL SUCH AS ABORTIONS
EUTHANASIA ASSISTED SUICIDE.
AND DIRECT STERILIZATION. THIS
WOULD ALSO INCLUDE IMPORTANT
FORMS OF CONTRACEPTION. NOT
ONLY DO SUCH YOUR ID'S CONFLICT
WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES
AND VALUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. BECAUSE THEY ARE
ROOTED IN RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE
THEY ALSO CONFLICT WITH
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION BECAUSE A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY IS AN BACK. IN OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION. CALIFORNIA
THE STATE PROTECTS PRIVACY AND
AUTONOMY IN REPRODUCTIVE
DECISION MAKING AND END OF LIFE
CARE MOREOVER IT IS UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE GOLD STANDARD OF
MEDICAL CARE AFTER SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND RAPE IS TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION.
HOWEVER EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION
IS NOT PROVIDED A CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS BECAUSE IT IS
CONSIDERED QUOTE A SEN BY THE
UNITED STATES CONFERENCE OF
CATHOLIC BISHOPS. TO PROVIDE
THIS TYPE OF MEDICAL CARE
INDEED EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION
IS NOT COUNCIL OR SPOKEN ABOUT
A CATHOLIC OSPITALS
CALIFORNIA'S AMONG MORE THAN A
DOZEN STATES TO REQUIRE
EMERGENCY CARE FACILITIES TO
MAKE AVAILABLE EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTION TO PATIENTS THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCE RATE. THIS
STANDARD TO WHICH USE HE IS
HELD IS COMPROMISED AND
VIOLATED WHEN IT BENDS TO
RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES NOW AS I
BEGIN TO CLOSE I ALSO WANT TO
SHARE THE FOLLOWING. IMAGINE
TRAINING OUR STUDENTS THAT
AFTER A GIRL OR WOMAN IS RAPED
THAT DENYING INFORMATION IS THE
PROPER FORM OF TREATMENT.
ACCORDING TO YOU SEE
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT 53% OF
YOU SEEK UNDERGRADUATE- ARE
WOMEN AND 43% OF OUR GRADUATE
ACADEMIC STUDENTS ARE WOMEN.
THE RISKS AND THE CHALLENGES
ARE REAL- WITH THIS. FINALLY I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY YOU SEE MEDICAL
EXECUTIVES. SOME OF ARTICULATED
THAT AFFILIATIONS WITH CATHOLIC
MEDICAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
NECESSARY BECAUSE THOSE
INSTITUTIONS SERVE THE POOR
INDEED IN SOMEINSTANCES
CATHOLIC CHARITIES AND OTHERS
HAVE STEPPED IN WHEN GOVERNMENT
HAS FAILED TO PROVIDE FOR THOSE
MOST IN NEED IN OUR SOCIETY.
THAT TYPE OF CHERRY COULD BE
APPLAUDED. THE RISING COST OF
HEALTHCARE IS A SERIOUS ISSUE
THAT DESERVES URGENT ATTENTION.
YET CATHOLIC CHARITIES WILL BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THAT IMPORTANT
WORK EVEN IN THE ABSENCE OF UC
AFFILIATIONS BECAUSE THEIR
DELIVERY OF CARE IS NOT
CONTINGENT ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. EQUALLY PROPONENTS
OF YOU SEE AFFILIATING WITH
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS ARTICULATE
THAT SOME OF THE BEST QUALITY
OF CARE FOR ADOLESCENTS
SUFFERERS OF COMPROMISE MENTAL
HEALTH IS TAKING PLACE AT
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS.
INTERVENTIONS TO AID IN THE
CARE OF THE YOUTH ARE GREATLY
IMPORTANT PERSONALLY I CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THESE ISSUES
HOWEVER THOSE INVALUABLE
SERVICES TO THE YOUTH ARE ALSO
NOT CONTINGENT ON YOU SEE
AFFILIATION. MORE OVER A YOUTH
SUFFERING FROM AN UNWANTED
PREGNANCY AND EXPERIENCING THE
TRAUMA ASSOCIATED WITH IT OR
RAPE WOULD BE DENIED THE
MEDICAL CARE AND COUNSELLING
NEEDED IF IT INVOLVED EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTION OR ABORTION AT A
CATHOLIC HOSPITAL. I APPLAUD
YOU FOR BRINGING US HERE TODAY
AND PROVIDING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
CONCERN REGARD TO RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATIONS AND THE WAYS IN
WHICH RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE HAS
COM TO CHALLENGE CONSTITUTIONAL
VALUES BOTH AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND ALSO AT THE STATE
LEVEL AS WELL. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO LEAD IN THIS REGARD
TO PROTECT THE SAFETY AND THE
HEALTH NOT JUST OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS BUT ALSO MEMBERS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. AND I WOULD
FURTHER STATE THAT IN A BROADER
SENSE- THE LIMITATIONS OF CARE
BY CERTAIN RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATIONS- EXPAND BEYOND
THESE COMMUNITIES AS WELL
ANYBODY WHO WILL EXPERIENCE AN
END OF LIFE MUST ALSO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE ISSUES
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME. IF THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN- I TOO WENT TO ADDRESS
WHAT LAW SCHOOL IN TIME TO
DIGEST ALASKAN HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR WORK THAT IS DONE
IN CATHOLIC INSTITUTIONS- BUT
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
THE SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS I
APPRECIATE YOUR GIVING US THAT
LEGAL LANDS WITH WHICH TO VIEW
IT- I WON RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COM LONGER WAS JOINED US
AND ASK HER IF SHE HAS ANY
REMARKS ARE QUESTIONS THAT SHE
WOULD LIKE FOR THE PANEL. I CAN
JUST- WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR
WOMAN FOR- PUTTING. TOGETHER
SUCH- A COMPREHENSIVE AND
INFORMATIVE- COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY. AND BEFORE USING YOUR
GRAVITAS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE STELLAR- A TESTIMONIAL SO
THANK YOU- FABULOUS OUTFIT TO I
WAS- I'M INCREDIBLY STRUCK BY
THE FACT THAT SO MANY
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE LIVING IN FEAR
AND IN PERIL. I'M OF AN
EXPANDING DOCTRINE THAT REALLY
I BELIEVE IS DESIGNED TO
MARGINALIZED- TO MAKE FOLKS
LIVE IN FEAR I'M INTO A RACE
OUR INSTABILITIES OUT OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES. AND IF WE CAN CREATE
GENERATIONS OF FOLKS WHO ARE
AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT THEIR
BODIES AND THEIR CHOICES- THEN
WE HAVE DONE OUR SELF A GREAT
DISSERVICE. I'M IN THE HISTORY
FROM WHICH SO MANY OF US COME.
I'M I WAS WONDERING HAVING SAID
THAT IF YOU COULD SHARE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT SORT OF
THIS SCOPING ASPECTS OF THESE
ER DE USE- YOU KNOW HOW IT
IMPACTS YOU KNOW AMBULANCE
DRIVERS TECHNICIAN IS NURSES
DOES IT- ARE THESE FOLKS ALSO
SORT OF TIGHTER TETHERED TO THE
YARD THESE AND IF THEY TOO ARE
NOW BEING ALLOWED. TO SERVE
DENY NORMAL SERVICES TO GET
WOMEN OR POOR FOLKS ARE FOLKS
IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES YOU KNOW THAT
MAYBE UNFORTUNATELY THEY WILL
ALSO BE DENIED IF THEY GET INTO
THOSE HOSPITALS AND YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT. I'M
TRAINING AND I'M- RESIDENTS AND
SO THAT ALSO LEADS ME TO BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW WE'RE
TRAINING. OUR DOCTORS AND
WAITING AND IF WE ARE SOMEHOW
NOW BECAUSE OF THIS ALMOST A
RADIC KADING KEY COMPONENTS OF
YOU KNOW OBGYN FAMILY PLANNING
CARE. AND WHAT THAT SAYS- TO
HOW YOUNGER GENERATIONS WILL BE
RECEIVING- YOU KNOW REAL
LEGITIMATE OBJECTIVE NON
RELIGIOUS INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR HELP. WITH OKAY SO ALL
OPEN AND THEN- SHARE THE WITH
MY FELLOW PANELISTS OPPORTUNITY
TO RESPOND TO YOUR CONCERNS. I
DON'T HAVE EMPIRICAL DATA WITH
REGARD TO AMBULANCE PROVIDERS-
BUT THE QUESTION THAT YOU RAISE
IN TERMS OF THE SCOPE IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE E. R. D.
IS- THEY GOVERN ALL CONTRACTS-
THAT ARE MADE WITH CATHOLIC
AFFILIATED I WILL. CATHOLIC
AFFILIATED INSTITUTIONS ARE
GOVERNED BY THE ER DIS AND
THOSE THAT COLLABORATE AN
AFFILIATE WITH THEM ARE THEN
GOVERNED BY WHAT THESE ER DIS
STATE AND NOT WILL INCLUDE ALL
STAFF ALL STUDENTS THE
RESIDENTS THE DOCTORS THE
NURSES THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN MEANS THAT THE
TRAINING THAT INDIVIDUAL.
RECIEVE MAY VERY WELL WENT BY
THAT INSTEAD OF WHAT HAPPENS TO
BE THE GOLD STANDARD IN TERMS
OF MEDICAL TREATMENT AND ONE
EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE WAS. WITH
REGARD TO A RATE IT IS THE GOLD
STANDARD BUT AFTER A RAPE- THE
INDIVIDUAL IS COUNSELED ABOUT
EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION AND
PROVIDED THAT OPTION NOT EVEN
THE COUNSELING WILL TAKE PLACE
I AT A CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE COUNSELED IN
THAT WAY IT'S CONSIDERED A SAN
AND CERTAINLY NOT PROVIDED.
EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION IF AN
INDIVIDUAL IS SUFFERING THROUGH
AN ECTOPIC PREGNANCY OR A
MISCARRIAGE. IT CANNOT BE
MANAGED AT A CATHOLIC OUR
INSTITUTION OR CATHOLIC
AFFILIATED INSTITUTION BECAUSE
THAT TOO IS CONSIDERED A SEN.
ONE CAN FIND A NUMBER OF CASES
JUST BY A VERY EASY SEARCH OF
WOMEN SENT HOME- IN NEAR DEATH
SITUATIONS BECAUSE THEY WERE
HAVING COMPLICATED MISCARRIAGES
I'M WHICH COULD LEAD TO
INFECTION. I AND THE INFECTION
LEADING TO DEATH AND THAT STILL
SENT HOME AT CATHOLIC COST
WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN INTO WILL
SYMPATHETIC ENOUGH DISABLED I
CAN. HOME PROVIDE TRIP FOR NOW
IS INDIVIDUALS BEEN DOES AND
FIVE IN VARIOUS. THESE CONCERNS
ARE REAL AND ONE THAT YOU ALSO
FLAG WHICH- IS NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART AS WELL AS THE QUALITY
OF THE TRAINING. THAT
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE I AM EATING
EXCITED BY THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THERE WILL BE LEGISLATION
COMING THROUGH YOUR BODY ABOUT
STUDENTS RECEIVING FREE HENCE
OF TRAINING WITH REGARD TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE UNITED STATES
LEADS THE DEVELOPED WORLD IN
TERMS OF MATERNAL MORTALITY-
ABORTIONS ARE CRITICALLY SO
THEY ARE INCREDIBLY SAFE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
SAFEST PROCEDURES. AND OTHER
PERSON A POSSIBLY. RIGHT
THEY'RE SAFER THAN A
COLONOSCOPY WHICH PEOPLE ARE
ADVISED TO REGULARLY GET ANYA
WE HAVE STUDENTS WHO ARE
GRADUATING FROM MEDICAL SCHOOLS
WHO DO NOT KNOW HELLO TO
PROTECT AND HELP A WOMAN WHO
WANTS A PERSON WHO WANTS
TERMINATE A PREGNANCY OR PERSON
WHO IS TO MANAGE MISCARRIAGE.
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE IN IN THE
WHAT A TRAGIC SITUATION TO SHOW
UP TO A HOSPITAL WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON. TODAY AS AS WE DO
SIX TYPE OF A PER SURE I'M ALSO
RENT TO THE TO FELLOW PANELISTS
TO MY WANT TO ADD. TO THAT SURE
I MEAN I'LL JUST ADD THAT IN
ADDITION TO RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES WERE ALSO DEALING
WITH HIS FELLOW FUSE ROLE. AND
YOU KNOW IT. WAS IN THE ONE AND
M. DRIVER A FARM DOCTOR IS ON.
STRAIGHTER YOU KNOW ANYONE IN
THE FIELD TO PUT THEIR OWN
RELIGION PREFERENCE NOW EVEN
THE MAN FIELD THE LIKE THE
JANITOR AT THE FRONT DESK
ASSISTANT IF THEY HAD AN
OBJECTION TO THE CARE YOU'RE
GETTING. AND IN THIS TIES INTO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT FEAR AND
PROMOTION OF FEAR WHILE I THINK
THAT HISTORY IS SO IMPORTANT
YES I'M AN ACADEMIC AND-
ACADEMIC MERIT. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GO BACK.
RIGHT TO WHAT WAS ROE V. WADE
WHAT THE HYSTERIA THAT'S BEEN
CREATED AROUND PREGNANCY AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH RIGHTS AND
JUSTICE IN THE UNITED STATES.
ONE COULD THINK THAT IT WAS A
SPLIT DECISION IT WASN'T. IT
WAS A SEVEN TO TWO OPINION IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. JUSTICE
BLACKMUN WROTE THE OPINION FOR
THE COURT JUSTICE BLACKMUN WAS
A REPUBLICAN HE WAS APPOINTED
BY RICHARD NIXON. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT IN READING THE
DETAILS OF THE CASE THE HISTORY
THAT. JUSTICE BLACKMUN BROUGHT
TO BEAR IN THE CASE. AS HE
INFORMED THE COURT AND ALL
THOSE WHO. READ THE CASE SENSE
THAN ABORTION I HAD BEEN LEGAL
IN U. STATES IT IS A LOT
HISTORY THE PILL IS A PRESS. OF
MAN. AND THREE. HEALTH CARE AND
BEING. A PERSON IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT THE HYSTERIC MORE
WITH YOU. ABOUT BECAUSE LET
MOVE. HAVE ALL. STRONG
ITERATION ABOUT ABORTION IN THE
UNITED STATES ACTUALLY CAME
AROUND THE TIME OF THE CIVIL
WAR. AROUND THAT TIME NEARLY A
100% OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE WAS BEING PERFORMED BY
WOMEN WHO WERE MIDWIVES HALF OF
WHOM WERE AFRICAN AMERICAN OR
BLACK WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
FORMERLY ENSLAVED WHITE WOMEN
IN NATIVE WOMEN AND IT WAS AT
THE RISE OF GYNECOLOGY WAS KIND
OF A PERFECT STORM. IT WAS THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SEEKING TO PUSH WOMEN OUT OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
CARVE OUT A FIELD JUST FOR MEN
SOUGHT TO CRIMINALIZE BOTH
MIDWIFERY AND ALSO ABORTION AT
THE SAME TIME. AND TO USE THAT
PLATFORM THEN AS AN ANTI
IMMIGRATION PLATFORM AS WELL.
THANK YOU A HIGHLY HONORED AS
WELL SO I APPRECIATE ALL THE IN
THING I HAVE TO GIVE US I'M-
AND I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO REMEMBER
IS THAT IN THE WAKE THE ROE V.
WADE CAME AT A TIME WHEN WOMEN
WERE DYING. WHICH IS PART OF
WHAT TOOK US TO WHERE WE WERE
AT THAT POINT AND THAT THAT.
THE RIGHT GUARANTEE UNDER ROE
V. WADE THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY
WHICH AS YOU SAID IS ALSO
INCLUDED IN OUR CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. IS STILL RIGHT
VERY MUCH PROTECTED. IN THIS
STATE AND ACROSS THE NATION.
I'M SO MY- QUESTION ABOUT- SOME
THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE PASSED.
SO I AM JUST LAST YEAR SIGNED
INTO LAW SENATOR LIVE HIS BILL
WHICH REQUIRES UC CAMPUSES TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION
I AM CONFUSED FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE HOW. AN AFFILIATION
OF THE CASTLE CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
UNDER WHICH UNDER CONTRACT LAW
THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH THE CONTRACT WOULD
INTERACT WITH OUR LEGISLATION
WHICH MANDATES PROVIDING
CERTAIN SERVICES. IT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION WHAT IT
REVEALS- HAPPENS TO BE THE
TROUBLE THAT YOU SEE CAN'T OVER
COM- OUT WITH THESE
AFFILIATIONS- BECAUSE THE
AFFILIATIONS MAKE VERY CLEAR
THAT- THE WHAT GOVERNS THE
RELATIONSHIP NOT JUST WITH THE
UC BUT ANY OTHER INSTITUTION
WILL IN FACT BE THESE RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES. AND SO IF THE YOU
SEE SIGNS CONTRACTS THAT ALLOW
FOR THE RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES TO
GOVERN- WHAT IT IS THAT WE DO
THEN THAT WOULD SEEM TO
MAINTAIN THAT THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN FOUGHT
FOR OUR STUDENTS CANNOT BE
PROVIDED FOR. IN THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. IF YOU KNOW MY
SENSE IS THAT THIS MAY NOT BE
LOOKED AT AS A ZERO SUM GAME.
IF IN FACT THE CHALLENGES THAT
ODD THERE'S A NEED FOR MORE
HOSPITAL BEDS IN CURRENTLY IN
THE UNITED STATES ONE IN SIX
HOSPITAL BEDS IS CATHOLIC IN
SOME IN SOME CITIES IT'S EVEN A
GREATER CONCENTRATION. IF OUR
CHALLENGES THAT WERE NOT ABLE
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WE WANT TO SERVE THE
DEFAULT ANSWER ISN'T THEN WE
MUST FOLLOW CATHOLIC YARD
TEASING AND- THE REAL QUESTION.
IS HOW DO YOU. GO ABOUT
ACHIEVING THOSE AIMS AND HOW DO
WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT WITH
REAL EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE AND
INFORMATION- AND SO THAT'S
WHERE I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
BE THINKING AND NOT JUST SIMPLY
WELL WE MUST. AFFILIATE WE
ACTUALLY DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE NOT.
SERVING OR COULD BE BETTER
SERVED BUT ONCE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT DATA THEN WE CAN
THINK ABOUT WHAT ARE THE TOOLS
THAT ARE NECESSARY OR THAT
SHOULD BE EMPLOYED. IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SERVICE
PEOPLE. WITH THE VALUES THAT
HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED THROUGH
THE UC SYSTEM AND THROUGH THE
STATE AND I AND I MUST SAY WHEN
WE LOOK AT. OF MATERNAL
MORTALITY AS I'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
SUCH A SPECIAL PLACE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS FOUGHT HARD TO
SAVE AND PROMOTE AND PROTECT
THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE THAT IT
SERVES. YOU KNOW WHILE TEXAS
HAS BEEN CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST YOU KNOW THE
DEADLIEST PLACE IN THE
DEVELOPED WORLD FOR PERSON TO
BE PREGNANT. CALIFORNIA IN
RECENT STUDIES IS CONSIDERED
ONE OF THE SAFEST PLACES AND
IT'S BECAUSE THE WORK THAT YOU
DO IT'S BECAUSE OF THE VALUES
THAT HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
WE CAN MEET THOSE KINDS OF
GOALS. AND I READ THE- THE
REPORT PUT OUT BY PRESIDENT OF
POLISH ON IS WORKING GROUP
WHICH I KNOW YOU SAT ON AND YOU
MENTIONED. YOU KNOW GETTING THE
EMPIRICAL DATA FIGURING OUT HOW
TO MEET THOSE SAME NEEDS ANY
AND AGAIN TO YOUR POINT AT THE
BEGINNING- CATHOLIC HOSPITALS-
SERVING IMPORTANT EVEN PART OF
OUR STATE IN PROVIDING CARE
THAT IS CRITICAL AND WE DON'T
WANT TO UNDERESTIMATE THAT- AND
I UNDERSTAND THE GOALS THAT
THOSE THAT LEAVES FILIATION
WILL HELP HAS. HAS THERE BEEN
CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO HOW TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS THROUGH
DIFFERENT MEANS BESIDES
AFFILIATION. NOW OKAY. THE
SHORT ANSWER DOWN YES I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING TO AN AND I
KNOW THAT- I DIDN'T LIKE THIS
MY REMARKS BUT- THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. WELL HE REVIEWS OR
WHOEVER. YOU'RE HER. REVIEWS AT
ALL NONPROFIT HEALTH CARE
TRANSACTIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH YOU ALL HAVE
GIVEN. THE OFFICE THAT. YOU IN
A SORORITY AND IT'S VERY BROAD.
WE DO NOT HAVE AUTHORITY OVER
THE UC SYSTEM. SO WE GET THAT
THAT QUESTION A LOT WOULD WE
DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY OVER THE
UC'S THERE INDEPENDENT OF US.
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING WE CAN'T GIVE YOU
THAT AUTHORITY. THAT WOULD BE.
I MEAN THAT BEER READING OF THE
CONSTITUTION I MEAN THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS AS YOU READ
IT. THAT WE CAN'T INTERFERE.
RIGHT AND IT. THAT HAMSTRINGS
LEGISLATURE'S WELL IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING I THINK IT'S IT
COULD BE AN OPEN QUESTION OR
ELSE OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AT LET'S DISCUSS SO- AND THEN
SO I JUST WANT TO LEAVE THE
LAST QUESTION THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK IS WE HAVE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT- WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH.
THE RELIGIOUS REFUSAL LACKS
TITLE TEN GAG RULE THE ACA ROLL
BACK AND THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
RE TO LEAD US TO THE PLACE
WHERE THESE DENIALS OF CARE-
ARE IMPACTING COMMUNITIES IN
VERY REAL WAYS- AND SO I JUST
WANT TO ASK EACH OF YOU TO
LEAVE US WITH WHAT IF YOU HAD A
WISH FOR THE PROCEDURE AND- WE
SHOULD WORK ON TO MOVE FORWARD
FOR THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA
WHAT THAT WOULD BE. I THINK I'M
IN A DIFFERENT POSITION THE
REST THE PANELISTS BECAUSE A
WEEK WE REPRESENT EVERYONE WHEN
THOSE LAWS GET. ULTIMATELY SUED
BY FOLKS WHICH IS. ISN'T TO SAY
THAT THEY'RE NOT WORTHY GOALS
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED OF ALL
THE WORK I MEAN I LOVE LIVING
HERE AND I THINK IT'S
PHENOMENAL THAT. YOU HAVE THIS
PANEL YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE PROACTIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE LAWS- SO I THINK
ANYTHING YOU CAN DO TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO SHORE UP- YOU KNOW
ALL THAT THE PLACES THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE TALKED ABOUT-
BUT MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING SO IN A WAY THAT WE'RE
BALANCING- AND NOT SO IN A WAY
THAT WERE CREATING A DICHOTOMY
THAT YOU KNOW. MADE MAYBE MEANS
IT'S NOT GONNA TRAVELING.
ALLEN'S WOULD BE ARE SORT OF
CAUGHT AS- I HEAR THAT. I'M
JUST BEING HONEST. REALITY LIVE
IN. YEAH WE'RE HAPPY TO WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAPPY TO SERVE. WELL I
GUESS I REPRESENT ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT COIN NOW AND
REPRESENTING PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA- AND
I'LL SAY THAT ON BOTH OF YOU
HAVE ALREADY BEEN TREMENDOUS
CHAMPIONS FOR US- IN IN MANY OF
THE LAWS THAT. YOU FAST AND IN
YOUR IN YOUR WORK BEFORE COMING
HERE- AND MY COLLEAGUE I THINK
LEAD SIMPLY SO MUCH OF OUR AS
YOUR- SHE'S THE VP OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD SO YOU'LL SEE SOME
OF THE BILLS THAT SHE'S WORKING
ON. ACROSS YOUR DESK BUT- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS INCREASING
ACCESS TO CARE THAT IS WHAT'S
AT OUR CORE- WE WANT TO EXPAND
SERVICES WE WANT TO REACH MORE
PATIENTS WE WANT THE TOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO REACH. PATIENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN WITH A SYSTEMATIC
BARRIERS AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
SEEN THOSE BARRIERS ONLY
INCREASE UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE PUBLIC
CHARGE ROLE WITH THE TITLE TEN
GAG RULE WITH- YOU KNOW THE
RELIGIOUS RULES ALL OF THAT-
AND SO WHAT WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR OUR- YOU KNOW THROUGH
FUNDING STREAMS THROUGH. YOU
KNOW CREASES IN PROVIDERS
GIVING PROVIDERS MORE TOOLS
GIVING US OUR PROVIDERS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ENABLE ESSENTIALLY
TO REACH MORE PATIENCE WITH-
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. YEAH I
WOULD ECHO EXACTLY WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE SAID AND I
WOULD FURTHER ROOTED IN HISTORY
AND THAT IS TO SAY THE REASON
WHY WE NEED ALL OF THAT HAS
JUST BEEN ARTICULATED BY MAGGIE
IS THAT. YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
LIVING THROUGH THE LEGACIES OF
UP OF WOMEN BEING SUBORDINATED
IN OUR COUNTRY. LIVING THROUGH
LEGACIES OF UNEQUAL TREATMENT
ON EQUAL OPPORTUNITY BY WOMEN
IN OUR CAUGHT. WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO RECTIFY THESE
HISTORIES AND RECTIFY THEM
THROUGH OUR COURTS AND WE KNOW
THAT- THE IMPORTANCE OF.
JURISPRUDENCE DOESN'T CHANGE
SITUATIONS OVERNIGHT AND I
THINK ABOUT AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESS THAT EVEN THOUGH WE WANT
TO PROTECT SERVICES AND ACCESS
ACCESS BECOMES CRITICALLY.
IMPORTANT AND ACROSS EVERY
REGARD WHETHER IT IS EDUCATION-
TESTING FOR S. T. EYES BOB
PRENATAL CARE ABORTION CARE-
POSTNATAL CARE AND I WILL CLOSE
ACTUALLY THINKING ABOUT FANNIE
LOU HAMER. BECAUSE IT I REFLECT
BACK ON OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
JURISPRUDENCE. THAT WOULD
SUGGEST THAT POOR WOMEN
SHOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ABORTION KEEPER THROUGH
MEDICAID. NAMING OF THE SUPREME
COURT THE CITY WHERE THE COURT
SAYS WELL YOU'RE WRONG THE
STATE IS A NOTHING TO PLACE
THESE WOMEN. IN THEIR
CONDITIONS OF POVERTY AND THEN
I THINK A FANNIE LOU HAMMER.
WHO ON THE WAY TO VOTE IN
MISSISSIPPI A STATE THAT FORCED
PEOPLE TO GUESS HOW MANY
BUBBLES ON A BAR OF SOAP. ARE
HOW A ONLY BE. AYE IN A BAR OF
JUST MEANS ARE RECITE STATE'S
CONSTITUTION IN ORDER TO VOTE.
AND I'M REMINDED OF WHAT HE WAS
SNATCHED OFF OF A US HER TO
VOTE ALONG WITH THEIR WEAPON.
WAS BEAT. UP IN A JAIL. I BEAT
ON HER LEG THE SHE'S. POLIO AND
THE SHEET. THE STORE ABOUT THE
BOTH THE CITY AND ALSO SO
BEFORE THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION SHE CAN. WITH SAYING
ALL COUNT THAT WE WANT TO VOTE.
I THINK THIS KIND AND IN THE
SAME OF ENERGY BEHIND THAT
LEGACY STILL HAUNTS US TODAY I
THINK WE'RE STILL FIGHTING FOR
EQUALITY IN IN THIS CASE AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO BE TREATED
WELL AND WITH DIGNITY WITH
REGARD TO OUR BODIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE DO NOT THIS
IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
EQUALIZERS WOMEN IN THE WORLD
IS CONTROL OF OUR OWN FUTURES
AND OUR OWN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SAID THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE FOR YOUR CREDIBLE
TESTIMONY. AND TO THIS DAY ONLY
BEGIN THE CONVERSATION I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TO
START IT. NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN
UP WELCOME UP OUR SECOND PANEL-
I. THINK I SEE IS SHANNON
OVERSEAS HERE WE READING.
PATIENT TESTIMONIES SHE IS.
CHEN IS NOT COMING SOMEONE ELSE
COMING OKAY WE'LL SEE COMES UP.
THE. OKAY. WE HAVE LAURA
FRIEDMAN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR-
AT THE BIG THE CENTER FOR
GLOBAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH UCSF.
AND PHILLIP BURLINGAME TO
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND GENDER
EQUITY DIRECTOR AT THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA. POLICE THAT YOU CAN
MOTOR THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
PROFESSOR OF LAW FROM UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF LAW. AND I AM I
BELIEVE THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED WILL BE JOINING US
SHORTLY TO PROVIDE HIS OWN
PERSONAL TESTIMONY- I MEAN HE
WOULD KEEP HIS WALK UP WHEN HE
GETS HERE. THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US- I THINK WE WILL
START WITH. THE PATIENT
TESTIMONY FROM MICHELLE AND
JOSH RIGHT BY DEAN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DAY I AM THE SONG. OKAY VERY
GOOD ON MY END. MY NAME IS DAY
I AM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR COURAGE- A
FILLING IN FOR SHANNON TO TALK
ABOUT MICHELLE IN CHAUCER'S
STORY. AFTER YEARS OF TRYING TO
GET PREGNANT MICHELLE AND JOSH
WERE HEARTBROKEN TO LEARN THEIR
FIRST PREGNANCY WOULD NOT
SURVIVE. TO ADD INSULT TO
INJURY THE CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
MISSION VIEJO CALIFORNIA WHERE
THEY WERE BEING TREATED. SHANE
THEM JUDGE THEIR CHOICES AND
DELAYED MICHELLE'S MEDICAL
MEDICAL CARE. THERE BY
THREATENING HER HEALTH THE
SHARED THEIR STORY WITH THE ALL
CARE EVERYWHERE PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND ENGAGEMENT
CAMPAIGN. THIS IS OUR STORY. MY
HUSBAND A LITTLE BIT YES.
THOUGHT BETTER. MY HUSBAND AND
I HAVE BEEN TRYING TO FOR YEARS
TO HAVE A CHILD AS SOON AS WE
FOUND OUT I WAS PREGNANT OUR
DOCTOR TOLD US THE AG HAD
IMPLANTED OUTSIDE MY UTERUS AND
A TOPIC PREGNANCY. WE WERE
DEVASTATED TO LEARN THAT IF THE
PREGNANCY CONTINUED I COULD DIE.
R. DOCTOR WANTED TO TREAT ME
RIGHT AWAY USING A RELATIVELY
SIMPLE OUT PATIENT PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR DOCTOR CAN
ONLY TREAT ME AT THE NEARBY
MISSION HOSPITAL PART OF ST
JOSEPH HEALTH. WHICH REQUIRED
THAT I UNDERGO A SERIES OF
ADDITIONAL ULTRASOUNDS TESTS
BLOOD WORK IN PAPERWORK TO
ENSURE I WASN'T TRYING TO GET
AN ABORTION. THE DOCTOR SAID
THIS IS THE TREATMENT. THIS IS
THE STANDARD. BUT THE HOSPITAL
SAID THEY DON'T WANT TO BE A
PART OF BACK. INSTEAD OF
GETTING THE SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD TREATMENT MY
DOCTOR WANTED MY HUSBAND AND I
FACED A WALL OF RED TAPE. AND
DELAYING TREATMENT OF THE NECK
TOPIC PREGNANCY WOULD HAVE TO
PUT MY HEALTH AND LIFE AT RISK.
IT WAS A QUESTION OF MY
SURVIVAL VERSES AN EMBRYO
THAT'S IN THE WRONG PLACE IT
HAS NO CHANCE OF SURVIVING. FOR
THEM TO PASS JUDGMENT TO
QUESTION IF I'M JUST MAKING UP
AN EXCUSE FOR TERMINATION IS
INSULTING. THIS RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTION OPPOSED THEIR
VERSION OF MORALITY ON ME. I
WAS SO ANGRY THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO SHE ME AND CALL ME A
LIAR. INSTEAD OF GETTING
MEDICALLY REQUIRED TREATMENT
FOR MY DOCTOR IN THE HOSPITAL
MY OWN COMMUNITY I HAD TO FIND
A NEW OBGYN. AND UNDERGO A MORE
INVASIVE PROCEDURE UNDER
GENERAL ANESTHESIA. THE LOSS OF
THE PREGNANCY WAS PAINFUL
ENOUGH BUT THIS DELAY FORCED ME
TO TAKE TIME OFF WORK. AND KERR
NOT ONLY ADDITIONAL MEDICAL
EXPENSES BUT ALSO THE EMOTIONAL
AND MENTAL BURDEN OF ANXIOUSLY
WAITING TO TERMINATE A MUCH
DESIRED PREGNANCY THAT COULD
NOT SURVIVE. I WAS GOING
THROUGH SUCH A HARD TIME AND
THEY MADE IT WORSE. THIS
SITUATION ROCK MY FAITH IN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION. AND IS MADE
ME AND MY HUSBAND QUESTION
WHETHER QUESTION WHETHER WE CAN
CONTINUE TO TRY TO HAVE A
FAMILY. WE'VE CONSIDERED GIVING
UP BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO BE
IN THE SITUATION IN WHICH WE
ARE DENIED CARE BECAUSE SOME
RELIGION WE DON'T EVEN BELONG
TO. TELLS US WHAT MORALITY IS.
WE ARE TELLING OUR STORY TODAY
BECAUSE WE WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THEY ARE NOT ALONE. THAT THEY
DO NOT NEED TO TAKE ON THE
JUDGMENT OR SHAMING OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO CARE
FOR THEM. IF OUR STORY CAN HELP
ONE PERSON FEEL LESS ALONE AND
PERHAPS MAKE A CHANGE AND IT
WILL BE WORTH IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
THE POWERFUL STORY. I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO MISS FRIEDMAN AND
SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
REMARKS. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY.
MY NAME IS LAURIE FRIEDMAN I'M
A MEDICAL SOCIOLOGIST AND A
BIOETHICIST. AND I'VE BEEN
CONDUCTING RESEARCH ABOUT
CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
RESTRICTIONS FOR MANY YEARS.
WHAT THAT RESEARCH HAS REVEALED
HAS CONCERNING IMPLICATIONS FOR
PATIENT AUTONOMY AND THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE. CATHOLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTIONS OCCUPY A
SIZEABLE SECTOR OF THE WHOLE
AMERICAN HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ONE
OUT OF EVERY SIX HOSPITALS AS
YOU HEARD- HOSPITAL BEDS IN THE
UNITED STATES IS IN A CATHOLIC
HOSPITAL WHERE OF THE RELIGIOUS
POLICIES GOVERN CARE. HOWEVER
IT IS QUITE VARIABLE BY STATE
IN SEVERAL STATES ABOUT 30% OF
HOSPITAL BEDS ARE IN CATHOLIC
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING FOR
EXAMPLE OHIO COLORADO ILLINOIS
AND IOWA. OVER 40% OF HOSPITAL
BEDS ARE IN CATHOLIC FACILITIES
IN WASHINGTON STATE ALASKA
SOUTH DAKOTA AND WISCONSIN.
NATIONALLY THE CATHOLIC SECTOR
OF THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM HAS
EXPERIENCE CONTINUOUS GROWTH
SINCE THE NINETIES- EVEN AS
OTHER SECTORS START TO SHRINK
PART OF THAT GROWTH HAS COME
FROM MERGERS ARE PARTNERSHIPS
OF SECULAR INSTITUTIONS FURTHER
ROADING OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED ACCESS TO THE FULL RANGE
OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
AT THIS POINT THE PROPORTION OF
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA SLIGHTLY ABOVE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE CARE. IN OUR
STATE IF THEY CONTINUE TO GROW.
MODERN CATHOLIC HOSPITALS A
COME TO LOOK AND FEEL LIKE MOST
OTHER US HOSPITALS WHAT MAKES
THEM UNIQUE IS THAT. CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS MUST FOLLOW THE US
BISHOPS RELIGIOUS POLICIES FOR
CARE AS YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SOMETIMES CALLED
THE RD'S. THESE POLICIES
RESTRICT A BROAD RANGE OF CARE
INCLUDING CONTRACEPTION
STERILISATION FERTILITY
TREATMENT MISCARRIAGE
MANAGEMENT GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE AND OF COURSE ABORTION.
THE IRAQIS DON'T SIT WELL WITH
MANY DOCTORS A NATIONAL SURVEY
FOUND THAT 52% OF OBGYN WHO
WORKING CATHOLIC HOSPITALS
REPORT CONFLICT WITH THEIR
HOSPITAL'S RELIGIOUS POLICIES
FOR CARE. HOSPITAL POLICIES IN
THE PEOPLE WITHIN THEM HAVE
CHANGED ONE HUNDRED YEARS AGO
IT WAS LIKELY THAT PATIENTS AND
EMPLOYEES OF CATHOLIC HOSPITALS
WERE LARGELY CATHOLIC AND
WANTED CARE DELIVERED ACCORDING
TO CATHOLIC DOCTRINE. TODAY
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS EMPLOYEE AND
SIR SERVED DIVERSE POPULATIONS.
RESEARCH SHOWSTHAT PATIENTS
CATHOLIC OR NOT REALLY CHOOSE A
HOSPITAL BASED UPON ITS
RELIGION AND INSTEAD PRIORITIZE
FACTORS SUCH AS QUALITY
INSURANCE GEOGRAPHY. THE
DIRECTIVE DO NOT REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF PREFERENCES OF EVEN
THE CATHOLIC WOMEN WHO DO USE
THEM NEVER MIND THE REST OF THE
POPULATION THEY SERVE. EVEN
THOUGH NEARLY ALL AMERICAN
WOMEN HAVE USED CONTRACEPTION
IN THEIR LIFETIME. AND ONLY 8%
OF CATHOLIC WOMEN FEEL
CONTRACEPTION IS MORALLY WRONG.
THE DIRECTIVES MANDATE THE
CATHOLIC HEALTHCARE
INSTITUTIONS MAY NOT PROMOTER
CONDONE CONTRACT CONTRACEPTIVE
PRACTICES. AND WHILE A THIRD OF
AMERICAN WOMEN INCLUDING
CATHOLIC WOMEN RELY ON
STERILIZATION TO LIMIT THEIR
FAMILIES SIZE THE DIRECTIVES
STRICTLY PROHIBITED. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS ETHICAL PROBLEM
A MUCH SMALLER PROPORTION OF
AMERICANS ACTUALLY AGREE WITH
CATHOLIC DIRECTIVES THEN THE
PROPORTION OF PROVIDERS
REQUIRED TO ABIDE BY THEM. SO
FUNDS INCLINED ARGUE WELL
PATIENTS SHOULD GO ELSEWHERE
AND PROVIDER SHOULD WORK
ELSEWHERE THAT'S NOT REALISTIC
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
HAVE GROWN FAR BEYOND. THEIR
APPROPRIATE FOOT PRINTS.
OCCUPYING HEALTHCARE TERRITORY
THAT COMPREHENSIVE PROVIDERS
NOW CANNOT. TODAY CLERGY HAVE
LITTLE TO DO WITH THE DAY TO
DAY RUNNING OF THE HOSPITAL AND
MARKETING HAS SOUGHT TO DE
CABALLOS AS THE IMAGE OF MANY
OF THE HOSPITALS. THIS CAN MAKE
IT HARD FOR PATIENTS TO
ANTICIPATE AND AVOID THE
RESTRICTIONS. A NATIONAL SURVEY
SHOWED THAT 37% OF WOMEN WHOSE
OWN HOSPITAL WAS CATHOLIC I.
DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT WAS. AND
AMONG THE WOMEN WHO DO KNOW
THAT THE HOSPITAL'S CATHOLIC.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR THE CARE THAT THEY'LL
RECEIVE. 70% EXPECT
STERILIZATION TO BE AVAILABLE
77% EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO GET
BIRTH CONTROL. 42% THINK YOU
CAN GET AN ABORTION FOR FETAL
ANOMALY. BUT THE DIRECTIVES
PROHIBIT ALL OF THESE THINGS.
IT IS OFTEN ASSUMED THE
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS TREAT THE
POOR MORE THAN OTHER HOSPITALS
HOWEVER NATIONALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA THEY PREFER PROVIDE
ONLY AN AVERAGE AMOUNT OF
MEDICAID AND CHARITY CARE. AND
THEY DO SO USING PUBLIC FUNDS
AND INSURANCE DOT DOLLARS LIKE
OTHER HOSPITALS NOT MONEY FROM
THE CHURCH NONETHELESS IN
NINETEEN STATES WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE OVER REPRESENTED AMONG
CATHOLIC HOSPITAL OBSTETRIC
PATIENTS MEANING THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO NEED REPRODUCTIVE
CARE IN A RELIGIOUSLY
RESTRICTIVE CONTEXT THAN WHITE
WMEN. IN A RECENT STUDY OF
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLANS IN
ILLINOIS SHOWED THAT BLACK AND
LATINO WOMEN WERE MORE LIKELY
THAN WHITE WOMEN TO BE ENROLLED
IN PLANS THAT SKEWED HEAVILY
TOWARD CATHOLIC HOSPITALS
MEANING THEY HAD LESS ON
COMPREHENSIVE CARE OPTIONS. ALL
OF THIS MAY CONTRIBUTE TO
EXISTING RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
MATERNAL HEALTH WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPOSED
TO FAMILY PLANNING BARRIERS AND
SUB STANDARD PRACTICES FOR
OBGYN COMPLICATIONS WHICH I'LL
EXPLAIN IN MORE DETAIL IN A
MOMENT. THE BISHOPS DIRECTIVES
FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM. THEY RUN
COUNTER TO BEST PRACTICES IN
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY
FAMILY PLANNING AND TRANS
GENDER CARE AND FROM RESULT IN
DISCRIMINATORY IN SUBSTANDARD
CARE. WELL RESEARCH HAS
REPEATEDLY DEMONSTRATED THAT
EVIDENCE BASED FAMILY PLANNING
METHODS ARE WIDELY EMBRACED BY
WOMEN IN CRITICAL TO THEIR
FAMILY'S HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THE DIRECTIVES PROHIBIT HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS FROM PROVIDING
THEM AND WOMEN FROM RECEIVING
THE CARE THEY SHOULD BE GETTING.
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS AGREE
THAT A NEW MOTHERS
CONTRACEPTIVE NEEDS ARE IDEALLY
ADDRESSED IN THE HOSPITAL AFTER
DELIVERY. BEFORE RETURNING HOME
TO TAKE CARE OF A NEWBORN AND
OFTEN OTHER CHILDREN AS WELL.
THIS IS A CRITICAL WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY IF SHE
DESIRES A STERILIZATION. IN ONE
STUDY HALF OF WOMEN WHO WERE
DENIED A WANTED STERILIZATION
EXPERIENCED AN UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY WITHIN A YEAR. IF A
NEW MOTHER MUST HAVE A SEPARATE
STERILIZATION PROCEDURE
ELSEWHERE LATER SHE HAS THE
ADDITIONAL RISK OF SURGERY AND
ANESTHESIA ESPECIALLY SHE WAS
HAVING A C. SECTION ANYWAY.
CATHOLIC POSSIBLE OBSTETRICIANS
I INTERVIEWED FOR MY RESEARCH
TOLD ME THAT WHILE THEY- MIGHT
BE ABLE TO DO TO DIRECT SOME
PATIENTS TO DELIVER ELSEWHERE
IF THEY WANT ACCESS TO
STERILIZATION SOMETIMES
PATIENTS GOING TO LABOR LABOR
AND JUST SHOW UP TO THE
CATHOLIC HOSPITAL NEEDING WHAT
THEY CAN'T PROVIDE. ONE DOCTOR
SAID EVERY TIME I'M ON CALL AND
PLAYING RUSSIAN ROULETTE
BECAUSE I FEEL I CAN'T LOOK
INTO A PATIENT'S ABDOMEN AND AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED. COMMIT
MALPRACTICE. I MEAN TO GO. TO
CLOSE SOMEONE UP AND SAY YOU
NEED ANOTHER OPERATION IS JUST
MALPRACTICE. PATIENTS WHO WERE
DENARD DENIED POSTPARTUM
STERILIZATION VOICE FRUSTRATION
AND REGRET. I INTERVIEWED A
WOMAN WHOSE DOCTOR HAD HAD
TRIED TO GET AN EXCEPTION TO
THE STERILIZATION POLICY FOR
HER BASED UPON A MEDICAL
CONDITION SHE HAD BUT THE
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS AT THE COULD
ETHICS COMMITTEE REFUSED SHE
SAID. QUOTE IF YOU LOOK AT ME
FROM A MEDICAL STANDPOINT I'M
NOT AGOOD PREGNANT PERSON I AM
AT HIGHER RISK OF DYING BECAUSE
I'M PREGNANT SO IT'S RIDICULOUS
TO ME YOU KNOW YOUR DOCTOR
SAYING YEAH BUT THE HOSPITAL
BOARD SAYING NO SO SORRY WHO
ARE YOU TO SAY. UNQUOTE NOT
BEING ALLOWED CONTRACEPTION AND
STERILIZATION CAN BE
EXTRAORDINARILY CONFUSING TO
PATIENTS WHO ARE HIGHLY
SENSITIVE TO THE SOCIAL
DISAPPROVAL OF ABORTION. BUT
CANNOT UNDERSTAND WHY THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER WOULD
RESTRICT THE MEANS OF
PREVENTING AT. FOR EXAMPLE ONE
PATIENT I INTERVIEWED DELIVERED
PREMATURE TWINS. AND A CATHOLIC
HOSPITAL AND WAS UNABLE TO
RECEIVE THE STERILIZATION SHE
DESIRED WHERE SHE WAS ALSO
DENIED CONTRACEPTION AFTER THE
BIRTH BOTH IN THE HOSPITAL AND
IN HER PHYSICIANS CLINIC WHICH
WAS OWNED BY THE CATHOLIC
HOSPITAL. WHEN ASKED HOW SHE
FELT ABOUT THIS SHE SAID QUOTE.
I WAS NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
I WANTED TO PREVENT GETTING
PREGNANT AGAIN AND THEY'RE NOT
PROVIDING ME WITH THE RESOURCES
LIKE IN THIS CASE BIRTH CONTROL
I FELT LIKE I WAS PRACTICALLY
BEING OBLIGATED TO NOT TAKE
BIRTH CONTROL. AND QUOTE. IN
SOME CATHOLIC HOSPITALS
PROVIDERS ACTUALLY DO PROVIDE
CONTRACEPTION BUT THEY DO SO.
BY USING A PRETEXT THAT THE
PATIENT NEEDS BIRTH CONTROL FOR
A DIFFERENT. NON CONTRACEPTIVE
REASON. AND GIVE THE
PRESCRIPTION FOR THAT REASON
HOWEVER THIS CAN ALSO BE VERY
CONFUSING FOR PATIENTS- I
INTERVIEWED ONE WOMAN WHO SAID
I ULTIMATELY HAD. AN
UNDERSTANDING PROVIDER WHO WENT
SO YOUR CRAMPS ARE REALLY BAD
WINK WINK WINK AT ME AND I
WENT. NO I'VE NEVER ACTUALLY
HAD CRAMP IN MY LIFE AND HE
SAID ARE YOU SURE YOU'VE NEVER
HAD A CRAMP BECAUSE I'M HEARING
YOUR CRAMPS ARE REALLY BAD. AND
HE WAS ULTIMATELY ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH THE
PRESCRIPTION FOR THE PILLS. SO
SHE WAS VERY CONFUSED. I DOCTOR
I INTERVIEWED- FOUND THIS
RITUAL TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLING ASPECT OF WORKING
UNDER KEPT THE BISHOPS POLICIES
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
ALWAYS WORK. SHE SAID QUOTE WE
HAD PATIENTS THAT WERE VERY
SICK WHO ARE PREGNANT AND
REALLY NEEDED NOT TO EVER GET
PREGNANT AGAIN. WOULD SIMPLY BE
CLOSED UP RIGHT AFTER C.
SECTION AND SENT OUT TO HAVE A
TUBAL LIGATION DONE AT AN
OUTSIDE INSTITUTION. AND YOU
KNOW PATIENTS WHO DIDN'T GET
THE THAT THEY HAVE A MEDICAL
PROBLEM FOR CONTRACEPTION. THE
DID ACT GET. WHEN OULD SAY
WELL YOU'RE- ARE YOU. UNQUOTE
THIS POSITION NOT TO PRESS IN
CAP HOSPITALS FOR BECAUSE A THE
WAY SUCH RESTRICTIONS DENIED
THESE WOMEN REPRODUCTIVE
AUTONOMY. WOMEN HAVING
MISCARRIAGES WHO SEE CARE AT
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS MAY ALSO
FACE RESTRICTED CARE. THIS
ARISES BECAUSE ABORTIONS ARE
COMPLETELY PROHIBITED BY THE
DIRECTIVES DOCTORS REPORT THAT
THEY MUST TEST FOR FETAL HEART
BEATS EVEN WHEN A MISCARRIAGE
IS CLEARLY INEVITABLE. IF A
HEART BEAT IS DETECTED THEN
THEY MUST WAIT FOR SIGNS OF
INFECTION BEFORE TREATING. THIS
IS NOT STANDARD PRACTICE IN A
NON RELIGIOUS SETTING WERE
OBGYN CARES MORE PATIENT
CENTERED. AND MISCARRIAGE
MANAGEMENT IS OFFERED TO REDUCE
PAIN AND RISK TO A WOMAN'S LIFE
AND HEALTH SUCH WAITING CAN
CAUSE DISTRESS FOR BOTH THE
PATIENT AND THE PHYSICIAN. ONE
CATHOLIC HOSPITAL OBGYN IT I
INTERVIEWED EXPLAINED QUOTE. WE
OFTEN TELL PATIENTS WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING IN THE HOSPITAL WHAT
BUT WATCH YOU GET INFECTED AND
WE OFTEN ASK THEM IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO BE TRANSFERRED TO A
HOSPITAL THAT WOULD GO AHEAD
AND GET THEM DELIVERED BEFORE
THEY GET INFECTED IT'S JUST
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM THERE
ALREADY AND A HARD PLACE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE PATIENTS
DISCHARGE THEMSELVES DRIVE
THEMSELVES AND THEN ADMIT
THEMSELVES TO THE NEXT
INSTITUTION. ON QUOTE. ANOTHER
POSITION A HIGH RISK
OBSTETRICIAN I INTERVIEWED
RECEIVED A TRANSFER PATIENT IN
HER REMOTE CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
FACILITY WHOSE WATER HAD BROKEN
BEFORE VIABILITY. THE FETUS. IT
TURNED OUT HAD MULTIPLE HEART.
ABNORMALITIES NOT COMPATIBLE
WITH LIFE. THEY CONSULTED
SPECIALISTS AND THE DOCTORS
DISCUSS THE POOR PROGNOSIS WITH
THE PATIENT. AND THE PATIENT
ASK THEM TO GO AHEAD AND INDUCE
LABOR ITH THE MEDICATION
RATHER THAN WAITING FOR
INFECTION. USING MEDICATION IN
THIS SCENARIO AGAIN AS STANDARD
PRACTICE IN MOST SAID SETTINGS
BUT THE PHYSICIAN WAS
REPRIMANDED AND ACCUSED BY
LEADERSHIP COMMITTEE- OF
VIOLATING THE ABORTION POLICY.
UPSET BY BEING REPRIMANDED FOR
DELIVERING APPROPRIATE CARE PER
THE FIELD OF HIGH RISK
OBSTETRICS THE DOCTOR WARNED
HER LEADERSHIP THAT SHE WOULD
START TURNING AWAY ALL PATIENT
TRANSFERS BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR WEEKS. BECAUSE SHE
DIDN'T HAVE CONFIDENCE THE
HOSPITAL WOULD ALLOW HER TO
MANAGE THEM PER THE STANDARD OF
CARE. ANOTHER OBGYN WHO WORKED
AT A CATHOLIC FACILITY
DESCRIBED A PARTICULARLY
DISTRESSING CASE OF A WOMAN
WITH A TWIN PREGNANCY THAT HAD
GONE WRONG. WHO SHOWED UP TO
THE HOSPITAL BLEEDING. AND
THERE WAS ONE. HEALTHY
APPEARING PREGNANCY BUT THE
OTHER WAS A MOLAR PREGNANCY. A
MOLAR PREGNANCY IS ONE THAT
CANNOT SURVIVE I'M- AND THE
TISSUE CAN BECOME CANCEROUS.
THREATENING A WOMAN'S LIFE SO
THE MEDICAL CONSENSUS IS TO
EVACUATE THE UTERUS COMPLETELY
AND IN SOME CASES TREAT WITH
CHEMO MEDICATIONS. THE DOCTOR
ASKED THE CATHOLIC ETHICS
COMMITTEE FOR PERMISSION TO
TERMINATE THE PREGNANCY BUT
THERE BECAUSE OF HER MEDICAL
CONDITION THEY REFUSED AND TOLD
HER TO SEND THE PATIENT
ELSEWHERE. I ALSO WANT TO SHARE
PATIENTS EXPERIENCE BEING
DENIED GENDER CONFIRMING
SURGERY. I WAS ABLE TO
INTERVIEW BOTH THE PATIENT AND
THE DOCTOR IN THIS CASE. WHICH
IS SIMILAR TO THE EXPERIENCE OF
EVAN MINTON WHO IS SPEAKING
TODAY AS WELL. THE DOCTOR HAD
PERFORMED. GYNECOLOGICAL
SURGERY ON THE PATIENT'S MOTHER
IN HIS CATHOLIC HOSPITAL AND
THEY HAD A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
SO. THE MOTHER AND THE
PHYSICIAN THOUGHT- HE WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THE SAME SURGERY FOR
HER TRIP TRANSITIONING SON. BUT
A NURSE CALLED THE SUN PRIOR TO
SURGERY TO GO OVER SOME DETAILS
AND SHE STARTED ASKING
MEDICALLY IRRELEVANT QUESTIONS-
HE SAID QUOTE. I NOTICED THE
QUESTIONS WERE VERY PERSONAL
LIKE SHE WOULD ASK ME WHAT WAS
I GETTING AND I TOLD HER WHAT I
WAS GETTING WHICH WAS A
HYSTERECTOMY AND WHATEVER AND
THEN SHE WAS SORT OF LIKE WHY.
I BRIEFLY JUSTANSWER DO I'M
GOING UNDERGOING A GENDER
REASSIGNMENT CHANGE YOU KNOW
AND SHE WAS. LIKE WHY SHE JUST
KEPT ASKING WHY AT A DAY AFTER
THAT AND THEN A DAY AFTER THAT
WHEN MY DOCTOR CALLED ME I
DISTINCTLY REMEMBER HE WAS LIKE
WE HAVE A PROBLEM. WHEN I
INTERVIEWED THE DOCTOR ABOUT IT
HE RECALL GETTING A PHONE CALL
TWENTY FOUR HOURS BEFORE THE
SURGERY SAYING THE PROCEDURE
COULD NOT BE DONE ON A
TRANSGENDER PERSON. HE PLEADED
WITH THEM BECAUSE THE PATIENT
I'VE BEEN WAITING AND NEEDED
THIS TO HAPPEN IN A SHORT
WINDOW OF TIME FOR MEDICAL AND
LOGISTICAL REASONS AND THEY
SAID NOW. AND THERE'S NOTHING
YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT WE'VE TAKEN
IT OFF THE BOOKS. PHYSICIANS
RESPONDED TO THE CONSTRAINTS
SORRY POSITIONS RESPOND TO THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE RELIGIOUS
POLICIES IN VARIOUS WAYS.
TRANSFERRING PATIENTS ELSEWHERE
FALSIFYING CHARTS. ARE
MISDIAGNOSED IN PATIENTS TO
WORK AROUND RESTRICTIONS WITHIN
THE HOSPITAL. DEALING CARE
UNTIL IT IS THEOLOGICALLY
JUSTIFIED IN ORDER TO SAVE
SOMEONE'S LIFE OR SIMPLY
DENYING IT WITH NO FURTHER
ASSISTANCE. I HOPE I HAVE
CONVEYED HOW RELIGIOUS
RESTRICTIONS CAN TIE THE HANDS
OF DOCTORS AND CONSERVE SUBJECT
PATIENTS TO THE LOGISTICAL
MEDICAL AND EMOTIONAL HARM A TO
NILES. AND MEDICAL
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKETHE ONES
THAT SHARE TODAY THE E. R. D.
IS ESSENTIALLY REQUIRE DOCTORS
TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST CERTAIN
PATIENTS AND TO PRACTICE OF
STANDARD OBGYN CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISREAD AND LIKE MANY
WOMEN I'VE EXPERIENCED A
MISCARRIAGE AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
BEING IN THE KIND OF CARE THAT
YOU DESCRIBE TODAY SO GLAD
WE'RE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
I'M GONNA TURN OVER TO MISS
BURLINGAME. TO GIVE US HER
OPENING REMARKS GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS PHILIP BURLINGAME
AND I'M THE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND GENDER EQUITY
DIRECTOR OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK TODAY AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOLDING. A HEARING ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. I'D LIKE TO
START MY REMARKS BY SAYING THAT
IT THE ACLU WE HAVE ALWAYS
STAUNCHLY DEFENDED RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM AS A CORE AMERICAN
VALUE. FOR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
MEANS THE ABILITY TO PRACTICE
ONE'S OWN RELIGION OR TO NOT
PRACTICE ONE. IT DOES NOT MEAN
THE RIGHT TO IMPOSE ONE'S
RELIGION ON OTHERS. AS
PROFESSOR FRIEDMAN STATED
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS DO NOT ONLY
HIRE CATHOLIC PROVIDERS OR
SERVE CATHOLIC PATIENTS WHO
SEEK RELIGIOUSLY RESTRICTED
CARE. ON THE CONTRARY THESE
HOSPITALS HIGHER PROVIDERS OF
MANY FAITHS AND NO FAITH. AND
THEY'RE OPEN TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC WHAT HAPPENS IN PRACTICE
THEN IS THAT THE HOSPITALS
THEMSELVES AND UP IMPOSING
RELIGION ON MANY. IF NOT MOST
OF THEIR PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS.
INCREASINGLY CATHOLIC HOSPITALS
ALSO VIE WITH SECULAR HOSPITALS
FOR MARKET SHARE. IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE THIRTY FIVE HOSPITALS
THE FOLLOW THE CATHOLIC ETHICAL
AND RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES AND
ANOTHER FOURTEEN THAT IMPOSE A
LESSER DEGREE OF CATHOLIC
RESTRICTIONS ON CARE. MORE THAN
ONE IN SIX HOSPITAL BEDS IN
CALIFORNIA IS IN A CATHOLIC
FACILITY AND THE LARGEST
HOSPITAL PROVIDER IN THE STATE
IS DIGNITY HEALTH A CATHOLIC
SYSTEM. AS WAS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED DIGNITY HEALTH MERCH
AND TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
CATHOLIC HEALTH INITIATIVES AND
THE COMBINED ENTITY IS NOW THE
SECOND LARGEST NONPROFIT HEALTH
SYSTEM IN THE NATION. AFTER
ASCENSION HEALTH ANOTHER
CATHOLIC SYSTEM. ALTHOUGH THE
MERGER DID NOT INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DIGNITY HEALTH
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE
CONSOLIDATION PROVIDES IT AND
OTHER CATHOLIC HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS WITH THE STRENGTHENED
POSITION AND THE HEALTHCARE
MARKETPLACE. IN SOME AREAS OF
THE STATE A CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
IS THE ONLY OPTION. FOR EXAMPLE
IN REDDING PREACH. PREGNANT
PATIENTS HAVE NO CHOICE OTHER
THAN MERCY MEDICAL CENTER A
DIGNITY HEALTH HOSPITAL FOR
SEVENTY MILES BUT ACCESSING
PREGNANCY RELATED CARE AT MERCY
OR ANOTHER CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
MEANS SUBJECTING ONESELF TO
RELIGIOUS RULES THAT OVERRIDE
PATIENT AUTONOMY AN EVIDENCE
BASED MEDICINE. THESE RELIGIOUS
RESTRICTIONS CAN PUT PREGNANT
PEOPLE'S HEALTH AND EVEN LIVES
AT RISK AS WE HEARD FROM A
SHELL AND JOSH'S STORY. AT THE
ACLU WE'RE LITIGATING THREE
CASES IN CALIFORNIA AGAINST
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS FOR DENIAL
OF CARE. I'M GONNA DISCUSS THEM
BRIEFLY BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
ILLUSTRATE BOTH THE STRENGTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING LAW AND
THE DANGEROUS RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
ARGUMENTS BEING MADE BY THE
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS. PUBLIC
HOSPITALS LIKE ALL OTHER
HOSPITALS ARE SUBJECT BOTH TO
THE STATE'S HOSPITAL LICENSING
LAWS INTO THE UNRUH ACT
CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAW. BUT IN OUR
CASES THE CATHOLIC HOSPITALS GO
SO FAR AS TO ARGUE THAT THEY
ARE AKIN TO A CHURCH. AND
THEREFORE SHOULD BE EXEMPTED
FROM THESE LAWS THAT WERE PUT
IN PLACE TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
PATIENCE. IS PROBABLY
UNNECESSARY TO DETAIL FOR YOU
HOW THE CHURCH AN INSTITUTION
THAT PROVIDES RELIGIOUS
SERVICES TO AN EMPLOYEES AND
SERVICE PEOPLE OF ITS OWN FAITH
IS FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
HOSPITAL TREATING THE MEDICAL
NEEDS OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC. IN
OUR FIRST CASE TOMORROW VERSES
DIGNITY HEALTH THE ACLU IN
COVINGTON AND BURLING ARE SUING
DIGNITY HEALTH ON BEHALF OF
REBEKAH TOMORROW AND PHYSICIANS
FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
RELATING TO THE DENIAL OF POST
PARTUM TUBAL LIGATION. AS WE
HEARD FROM PROFESSOR FRIEDMAN
PROVIDING A TUBAL LIGATION
DIRECTLY AFTER CHILDBIRTH IS
THE STANDARD OF CARE. BUT
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS AVE A
RELIGIOUS POLICY AGAINST
PROVIDING CONTRACEPTIVE
SERVICES AND THEREFORE
ROUTINELY DENY PATIENTS THIS
IMPORTANT HEALTH CARE. HOWEVER
AS WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH THE
LAWSUIT THE SITUATION IS EVEN
MORE COMPLICATED BECAUSE IN
FACT MANY CATHOLIC HOSPITALS DO
PROVIDE SOME TUBAL LIGATION TO
SOME PATIENTS. HOW THEY DO SO
IS BOTH DEEPLY TROUBLING AND IN
VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
LEGISLATURE ACTED TO BAN WHAT
WAS THEN DISTURBING COMMON
PRACTICE. HOSPITAL'S DENYING
ACCESS TO TUBAL LIGATION IS
BASED ON THEIR ASSESSMENT OF
WHETHER THE PREGNANT PERSON
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO STOP
HAVING CHILDREN. THIS WAS THE
FLIP SIDE OF THE EGREGIOUS
EUGENICS POLICY THAT INFLICTED
STERILIZATION ON OTHER PEOPLE
PRIMARILY WOMEN OF COLOR
AGAINST THEIR WILL. THE TOOL
HOSPITALS USED KNOWN AS THE ONE
TWENTY RULE. REQUIRED THE
PREGNANT PERSONS AGE MULTIPLIED
BY THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN REACH
THE NUMBER ONE TWENTY BEFORE
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO A TUBAL
LIGATION. THE LAW NOW STATES
THAT HAVE HOSPITALS PROVIDE ANY
STERILIZATION OPERATIONS THEY
MAY NOT USE NON MEDICAL
CRITERIA TO DETERMINE WHICH
STERILIZATIONS TO PROVIDE.
DESPITE THIS CLEAR LAW DIGNITY
HEALTH HOSPITALS ARE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT IS PROHIBITED
STRIPPING PATIENTS OF THEIR
ECONOMY AND MEDICAL DECISION
MAKING AND USING AGE NUMBER OF
BIRTHS AND OTHER NON MEDICAL
CRITERIA TO DECIDE TO WHICH
PATIENTS THEY WILL PERMIT A
TUBAL LIGATION. THE FINAL
DECISION IS MADE BY A NUN NOT A
MEDICAL PROVIDER. THE OTHER TWO
CASES PERTAIN TO DENIALS OF
GENDER FIRMING HYSTERECTOMIES
TO TRANSGENDER MAN. EVAN MINTON
ONE OF OUR CLIENTS IS HERE TO
TELL HIS POWERFUL STORY SO I
WILL LEAVE THAT TO HIM. BUT I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT BOTH
MISTER MINTON AND OLIVER NIGHT
WHO WAS DENIED CARE AT SAINT
JOSEPH HOSPITAL IN EUREKA. WERE
DENIED CARE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRANSGENDER THE ESSENCE OF
IDENTITY BASED DISCRIMINATION
THAT THE UNDER ACT IS INTENDED
TO PROTECT AGAINST. CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS INCLUDING THE
HOSPITALS THAT DENIED CARE TO
MISTER MINTON AND MISTER KNIGHT
REGULARLY PROVIDE
HYSTERECTOMIES TO CISGENDER
WOMEN AND IN FACT HAD SCHEDULED
THE PROCEDURES FOR BOTH OF OUR
CLIENTS IT WAS ONLY WHEN THE
HOSPITAL'S LEARNED THAT MISTER
KNIGHT AND MISTER MINTON OR
TRANS GENDER. THAT THEY DENIED
THEM CARE. WITH RESPECT TO
MISTER MINTON DIGNITY HEALTH
HAS ARGUED THAT THEY DID NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST HIM
BECAUSE HE WAS ABLE TO ACCESS
CARE AND A NON CATHOLIC DIGNITY
HEALTH FACILITY AT A LATER
TIME. SIMILARLY PROPONENTS OF
AFFILIATIONS BY THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA THAT IMPOSE
RELIGIOUS RESTRICTIONS ON YOU
SEE PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS.
ARGUE THAT IF YOU SEE PROVIDERS
ARE ABLE TO TRANSFER DENIED
PATIENTS TO ANOTHER FACILITY
THERE PROVIDING APPROPRIATE
CARE TO THAT PATIENT. BUT LET'S
STEP BACK AND CONSIDER THAT FOR
A MOMENT. AT THE HOSPITAL DOES
NOT HAVE THE STAFFING LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE OR INFRASTRUCTURE TO
PROVIDE CERTAIN MEDICAL
SERVICES TO PATIENTS IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT FOR THEM TO
TRANSFER THOSE PATIENTS TO
ANOTHER FACILITY. I HAVE A
HOSPITAL TRANSFER PATIENTS
BASED SOLELY ON THEIR IDENTITY
THAT IS SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
OUR LAW IT IS NO DIFFERENT TO
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON GENDER
IDENTITY THAT IT WOULD BE FOR
HOSPITAL TO REFUSE TO TREAT ME
BECAUSE I AM A WOMAN. OR AN
ATHEIST. IN ALL THREE OF THESE
CASES AS THEY PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THE CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS ARE ALSO MAKING
SWEEPING CONSTITUTIONAL
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM ARGUMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
REFUSE TO FOLLOW STATE
LICENSING LAW AND STATE
NONDISCRIMINATION ON.
SPECIFICALLY THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH
PATIENTS THEY PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES TO. SO LET'S TAKE THAT
AND FOR A SECOND THESE
HOSPITALS WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AND THE NINE MEDICAL
CARE BASED ON WHETHER THEY DEEM
AN INDIVIDUAL PATIENT MORALLY
WORTHY. THUS FAR THE ONLY
APPELLATE COURT IN CALIFORNIA
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE HAS AGREED
WITH US BUT WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IN THE FEDERAL
COURTS. FOR TOO LONG CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS HAVE ACTED WITH
IMPUNITY AND MANY HAVE LISTEN
TO THEM WHEN THEY HAVE SAID
THAT THEY ARE ACTING FOR THE
GREATER GOOD. BUT THEY'RE
DENYING CARE AND THEY'RE
DISCRIMINATING. IT IS TIME TO
SHINE A LIGHT ON WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING IN THESE HOSPITALS
AND IT'S TIME TO HOLD OUR STATE
INSTITUTIONS LIKE YOU SEE.
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS FACILITATE THESE
RESTRICTIVE PRACTICES. FREEDOM
OF RELIGION SHOULD NOT MEAN A
LICENSE TO DISCRIMINATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS BROWN GAME
FOR THAT POWERFUL TESTIMONY TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR STATE.
MISTER MINTON I'D LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO YOU TO TELL YOUR STORY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED. MERRY BAND.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I WANNA THINK
TO CHAMPION. RIGHT HERE AND
SHARE OUR QUE HAN AND-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM WALKER SEC
I'M MY NAME IS EVAN MEN CAN AND
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE AND
WHILE SPEAKING OUT CAN BE
CHALLENGING HELP ME FURTHER
RECLAIM MY VOICE IN MY POWER
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. I'VE GIVEN MY
STORY BEFORE CONGRESS TWO WEEKS
AGO. BEFORE THE BOARD OF
REGENTS UC BOARD OF REGENTS IN
MAY I AM IN THE NEW YORK TIMES
AN OFFICIAL COURT DOCUMENTS. IN
INTO MANY MEDIA OUTLETS TO KEEP
TRACK OF. THAT MY TESTIMONY AT
THIS HEARING WILL BE A BIT
DIFFERENT FOR ME. THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY AS MY FAMILY. AND I
PLAN ON OPENING MYSELF UP A BIT
MORE. IN GIVING YOU MORE OF
MYSELF BECAUSE OF ALL THAT I'VE
GOTTEN IN RETURN. I GREW BEEN
PRETTY CONSERVATIVE EVER MORE I
THINK AT LEAST TWENTY VIEW ON
THIS PANEL IS FAMILIAR WITH
THAT PLACE. I WAS ONE OF THE I
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST OPENLY
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE THAT I EVER
NOW. AND I WAS THAT CERTAINLY
THE FIRST OPENLY TRANSGENDER
PERSON THAT MY FAMILY EVER NOW.
AND AM I DIDN'T KNOW THAT I WAS
TRANS INTEL MY LATE TWENTIES.
EV BUT I GREW UP WITH A SENSE
OF SHAME ABOUT MYSELF NEVER
WANTING MYSELF TO BE MY HOME.
AND I WENT THROUGH- SO MUCH TO
TRY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT SHAME AND FIND OUT WHERE
THAT SHE WAS COMING FROM AND I
WENT TO CHURCH I WENT TO
COUNSELING BUT I COULD NEVER.
REALLY FIND OUT WHY. I'M IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN I WAS IN A
PRODUCTION OF THE ****
MONOLOGUES. AND SOME FOLKS
MIGHT HAVE SEEN A AT THE CAST
INCLUDED. AMY BROWN JODY HEX
AND KERRY MARTIN WHO IS HERE
TODAY- AND A PART OF A
TRANSGENDER WOMAN. AND ALL THE
SENATE CLICKED FOR ME. THIS IS
A- I'M TRANS GENDER. AND I
EXPERIENCED A BRIEF HONEYMOON
PERIOD THAT ACT QUICKLY
DEVOLVED INTO WHAT I
INSTINCTIVELY REFERRED TO AS-
THE DARK NIGHTS OF MY SOUL. I
THOUGHT THAT I COULD NEVER
ACCOMPLISH MY HOPES AND DREAMS
BECAUSE OF WHO I AM. AND ONE OF
MY HOPES WAS TO WORK IN THE
CAPITAL AGAIN. I'D ENTERED THE
BUILDING AS A WOMAN NAMED
HEATHER. AND THEN LEFT THE
BUILDING TO BE A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE. IN MY THOUGHTS. AND
MY DREAMS OF RETURNING TO THE
CAPITAL TO MAKE WIDESPREAD
POSITIVE CHANGE THROUGH THE LAW
WE'RE NO LONGER I THOUGHT THAT
THEY WERE NO LONGER OPEN TO ME.
AND I CAN'T DESCRIBE HOW MUCH
THAT HURT. FAST FORWARD TO
TODAY AND I'M PROUD TO BE
CONSIDERED THE FIRST OPENLY
TRANSPORTATION TO HAVE EVER
WORKED AT THE CAPITOL. THAT
WHEN I WAS FINALLY READY WHEN I
WAS FINALLY READY TO PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCE THIS IS WHO I AM I
MADE THE DECISION TO BE PUBLIC
ON FACEBOOK. I KNEW THAT THERE
WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE STEPS IN MY
TRANSITION THAT WOULD BE NO
NOTICEABLE TO PEOPLE AT YOU
KNOW WARY NOW CLOTHING
EVENTUALLY CHANGING TO MALE
PRONOUNS FACIAL HAIR I'M STILL
WAITING FOR THE FACIAL HAIR.
AND AT THE TIME I FIGURED THAT
I COUD EITHER WALK IN MY STORY
AND OWN IT OR COULD LOSE
CONTROL OF MY NARRATIVE AND
SIMPLY SUBJECT MYSELF TO OTHERS
TALKING ABOUT AND SPECULATING
ABOUT ME BEHIND MY BACK. AND I
CHOSE TO DO MORE OF THE FORMER
IN AN ATTEMPT TO AVOID. THE
LATER. BUT THAT SHARING EVOLVED
INTO SO MUCH MORE. IT EVOLVED
INTO A HUGE COMMUNITY OF
SUPPORT. AND WHILE A FACED
EGREGIOUS BALLOTS OF BULLYING
WITHIN THESE WALLS INCLUDING
FROM A CURRENT REPUBLICAN
SENATOR WHO CORNERED ME IN A
RESTROOM. DEMANDING TO KNOW IF
I WAS A MAN OR A WOMAN THE LOVE
I RECIEVE HERE WAS MORE THAN I
COULD EVER IMAGINE. AND IT HAS
BEEN TRULY HUMBLING AND ON FIRE
IN. I KNOW I NEVER GUESSED THAT
THIS WOULD BE MY LIFE TODAY.
BUT NOT THERE WAS THE SUPPORT
MORE OBVIOUS AND NEEDED. THEN
WHEN I WAS DENIED MEDICALLY
NECESSARY IN TIME SENSITIVE
HEALTH CARE BECAUSE OF WHO I AM.
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I WAS IN THE PROCESS OF
UNDERGOING A SERIES OF MEDICAL
TREATMENTS STEMMING FROM MY
DIAGNOSIS OF GENDER DYSPHORIA.
AFTER MY DOCTORS DETERMINED
THAT A HYSTERECTOMY WAS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY I WAS
SCHEDULED TO UNDERGO THE
SURGERY AT MERCY SAN JUAN
MEDICAL CENTER. AT THE HOSPITAL
IN THE DIGNITY HEALTH CHAIN.
ANDI DID NOT KNOW MUCH ABOUT
WHERE HE SAN JUAN MEDICAL
CENTER OR DIGNITY HEALTH BUT I
KNEW THAT MY SURGEON REGULARLY
PERFORM HYSTERECTOMIES AT THAT
HOSPITAL. TWO DAYS BEFORE MY
SURGERY DATE I NURSE CALLED ME
TO GO OVER THE DETAILS AND I
MENTIONED THAT I WAS
TRANSGENDER. THE VERY NEXT DAY
A DAY BEFORE MY SURGERY BUT
SUPPOSED TO TAKE PLACE. THE
HOSPITAL CALLED MY SURGEON TO
INFORM HER THAT MY SURGERY HAD
BEEN CANCELED. THE REASON
BECAUSE IT WAS PART OF MY
GENDER TRANSITION. I REMEMBER
WHERE I WAS WHEN MY DOCTOR
DELIVERED THE NEWS TO ME. SHE
CALLED ME AND CALMLY BUT
SORROWFULLY BUT ALSO WITH A
SENSE OF OUTRAGE TOLD ME THAT
WHILE SHE HAD ANOTHER
HYSTERECTOMY ON THE BOOKS
DIRECTLY AFTER MINE THAT THE
HOSPITAL WAS NOT CANCELING. THE
HOSPITAL IS CANCELING MY
HYSTERECTOMY BECAUSE I AM TRANS
GENDER. I WAS IN MY PARENTS
HOUSE IN THEIR BEDROOM IN AT
THAT MOMENT I WAS SO DEVASTATED
THAT I JUST LAPPED TO THE
GROUND. BECAUSE I HAD STRUGGLED
MY WHOLE LIFE BASED ON WHO I AM
AND I WAS FINALLY ABLE TO COME
TO TERMS WITH WHO I AM AND
ACCEPT WHO I AM AND I FELT SO
HELPLESS. AND DISTRAUGHT
BECAUSE THIS HOSPITAL WAS
DENIED ME CARE BASED EXACTLY ON
THOSE GROUNDS. HEY ANY A MANY
MANY FOLKS IN THIS CAPITAL
COMMUNITY HAVE TROUT TRAVELED
THAT PORTION OF THE ROAD WITH
ME. AFTER THOSE WHO DID AND-
NOT ONLY DID THIS CAN'T AT THIS
HOSPITAL CANCEL MY SURGERY BUT
TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE THE FACT
THAT THE SURGERIES CANCELED
THEN PUT ALL OF MY OTHER
TREATMENTS THAT I HAD SCHEDULED
IN FOR. BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXPERIENCED DELAYS IN GETTING
CARE THAT I NEEDED THE TIMING
OF MY HYSTERECTOMY WAS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. IF I
COULDN'T FOLLOW THIS TIGHTLY
SCHEDULED COURSE OF TREATMENT
MY GENDER DYSPHORIA WOULD GET
PROGRESSIVELY WORSE. FOR ME
WHAT THAT MEANS IS A FEELING
THEY HAVE MORE AND MORE IN
SOCIETY A FEELING OF WANTING TO
CRAWL OUT OF MY SKIN. IT IT'S
MY HEALTH AND IT'S MY WELL
BEING. I WAS FORTUNATE THAT-
BECAUSE OF MY CONNECTIONS TO
PEOPLE IN POWER AND BECAUSE OF
MY OWN WILLINGNESS TO BE VOCAL
I WAS ABLE TO FIGHT. AND GET MY
HYSTERECTOMY PERFORMED AT A
DIFFERENT HOSPITAL. BUT THE
EXPERIENCE OBVIOUSLY LEAVE
SCARS. I HAD NO IDEA PRIOR TO
SEEKING A HYSTERECTOMY THAT MY
LOCAL COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
COVERED BY MY INSURANCE WAS A
CATHOLIC HOSPITAL OR THAT THEY
WOULD ARGUE THAT RELIGIOUS
DOCTRINE PERMITS THEM TO DENY
MEDICALLY NECESSARY CARE JUST
BECAUSE A PATIENT HAPPENS TO BE
TRANS GENDER. I NOW KNOW THAT
THE US CONFERENCE OF CATHOLIC
BISHOPS WHICH DETERMINES
MEDICAL POLICY. FOR MOST
DIGNITY HEALTH HOSPITALS
BELIEVE THE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE.
DO NOT EVEN EXIST. THINK ABOUT
THAT BISHOPS DETERMINING
MEDICAL POLICY OUR TAX FUNDED
HOSPITALS THAT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST TAXPAYERS. SINCE THOSE
TWO PHONE CALLS THE ONE WITH
THE DIGNITY HEALTH NURSE AND
THE ONE WITH MY OWN DOCTOR MY
ADVOCACY HAS LED ME IN A NEW
DIRECTION. AND I WANT TO SHARE
A SAD STATISTIC RIGHT NOW NOT
THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN SAD ENOUGH
ALREADY. BUT AS OPPOSED TO ONE
POINT 6% IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. ACCORDING TO THE
RESEARCH THAT I'VE DONE I AM.
40% OF THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY WILL ATTEMPT SUICIDE
AT LEAST ONCE IN THEIR LIFE 40%
THIS NUMBER JUMPS TO SIXTY.
PERCENT OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN DENIED MEDICAL
CARE GETTING ANTI TRANS GENDER
BIAS. I THAT TO TAKE TO GET
FROM THE WILLIAMS INSTITUTE OF
UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW 60% YOU ARE
MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT SUICIDE
AFTER EXPERIENCING MEDICAL CARE
FROM BEING FROM BEING DENIED
BEING DISCRIMINATED. THEN YOU
ARE LESS LIKELY TO COMMIT
SUICIDE THAT'S NUTS IT'S NUTS.
I'M SO WHILE I CONSIDER MYSELF
TO BE FULLY ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF MY TRANSITION I FEEL LIKE I
WOULD BE SHIRKING MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MY COMMUNITY
IF I DIDN'T CONTINUE THIS
FIGHT. NO MATTER HOW HARD IT IS.
I SIMPLY DON'T WANT WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME TO HAPPEN TO
ANYBODY ELSE BUT THE TRUTH OF
THE MATTER IS THAT WE KNOW THAT
IT DOES. TRANSFERABLE A ROAD
TEAM ONLY BEING TURNED AWAY BY
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS. AND THIS
IS EVEN MORE DEVASTATING AS MY
FELLOW PANELISTS HEAD ON. IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE THERE IS NO
WHERE ELSE TO TURN. AND IN FACT
THE ONLY THING THAT MAKES MY
EXPERIENCE UNIQUE IS THAT A
BECAME HIGH PROFILE. AND I DID
YEAH SO RIGHT NOW. I'M A I'M
CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN TWO BIG
BATTLES. THE FIRST IS MY
LAWSUIT THAT THE ACLU ACLU AND
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
HOLDER IS LAW FIRM COVINGTON
AND BURLING HAVE FILED ON MY
BEHALF AGAINST DIGNITY HEALTH
AND THAT WAS AT PUT FORWARD IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. AND
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT MATT
PHELPS AND PHILLIPS REPRESENTS
DIGNITY HEALTH AGAINST ME. AND
IN OTHER ANTI DISCRIMINATION
COURT CASES AGAINST DIGNITY
HEALTH. JUST LAST FALL A
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEAL
AGREED WITH ME THAT I SUFFERED
DISCRIMINATION WHEN THE
HOSPITAL CANCELED MY SURGERY.
WHAT MY COURT YEAH I SAID
THAT'S FANTASTIC YES STILL A
BIT OF GOOD NEWS IN ALL OF THIS
YEAH HEY YEAH- I HAVEN'T DONE
THE CONFETTI UP YET BUT- WELL
MY CASES THEN PENDING IN THE
COURTS. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAITED SOME. IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
ISSUED A PROPOSED RULE THAT
MISS FINE TASTE RAINER
MENTIONED EARLIER ENTITLED
PROTECTING STATUTORY CONSCIENCE
RIGHTS AND HEALTH CARE. AS
OPPOSED TO WORKING TO PROTECT
PATIENTS AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE THE ENTIRE PURPOSE
OF WHAT I CALL THIS REFUSAL OF
CARE ROLE. IS TO ENABLE PEOPLE
AND ENTITIES TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PATIENTS AND LIMIT CARE
AND THE NAME OF RELIGION. AND
ITS ARGUMENT AS TO WHY THIS
RULE WAS NECESSARY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MENTIONS THREE
COURT CASES. MINE IS ONE OF
THEM. PEOPLE OFTEN MISS THE
HUMAN TOLL THAT THIS TAKES.
NEEDLESS TO SAY IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT. ONE MY COURT CASE
REMAINS UNDER WAY I'M INVOLVED
IN A SECOND FIGHT. TO PREVENT
RELIGIOUS RESTRICTIONS ON UC
PROVIDED HEALTH CARE AND
ACTUALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LIMON THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING OUT ON THIS. IS REALLY
IMPACTFUL. AND THE UC I BELIEVE
IS THE THIRD LARGEST HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER IN OUR STATE. AS
A U. SEAL I'M I FEEL
PARTICULARLY PERSONAL TIED TO
THIS. LAST YEAR I WAS PART OF A
LARGE COALITION THAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN DEFEATING A
PROPOSAL TO FORMALIZE IN VASTLY
EXPANDED PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
UCSF AND DIGNITY HEALTH. I
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS AND I'M PROUD
TO HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
THAT VICTORY. IT'S NOT SO WHAT
WE DISCOVERED IN THE PROCESS.
INCREASINGLY DISTURBED
INCREDIBLY DISTURBINGLY HOWEVER
IN THE COURSE OF THAT FIGHT IT
WAS UNCOVERED. THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD PARTNERSHIPS WITH DIGNITY
HEALTH HOSPITALS AT EVERY
SINGLE UC MEDICAL CENTER. AS AS
AS PROFESSOR I CAME OUT H
LL SOON TESTIFY THE UC IS NOW
SEEKING TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THIS TYPE OF PARTNERSHIP THREE
NEW GUIDELINES. THE
PARTNERSHIPS FORCED THE UC
DOCTORS AND MEDICAL STUDENTS
PLACED IN THESE RELIGIOUS
HOSPITALS TO DENY CARE BASED ON
RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE. SOUND
FAMILIAR WHICH ALSO IMPACTS ALL
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED THAT CARE. ESSENTIALLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
SANCTIONING AND PARTICIPATING
IN THE SAME HARMFUL POLICY THAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING IN THEIR HARMFUL
REFUSAL OF CARE ROLE.
IRONICALLY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CAN'T EVEN
IMPLEMENT THEIR ROLE YET
BECAUSE THANKFULLY IT'S BEING
HELD UP IN THE COURTS. IT'S
UNTHINKABLE WHAT THE UC IS
DOING RIGHT NOW IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE THEIR MARKET SHARE. I
FIND IT EVEN MORE TROUBLING.
THAT THE UC IS SAYING THAT THEY
NEED TO DO A- IN ORDER TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE YES. UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ABSOLUTELY NEED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. BUT WHAT
THESE COMMUNITIES NEED AND
DESERVE LIKE EVERY SINGLE OHER
COMMUNITY IS ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE SCIENCE BASED
HEALTHCARE. IT'S NOT HOSPITALS
THAT WILL LIMIT CARE AND THEN
BETRAYED THEM IN THEIR TIME OF
NEED. ARE YOU SEE BOTH A BOARD
OF REGENTS VOTE ON THIS MATTER
IS FORTHCOMING. THE AND THAT'S
WHY I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND TO TESTIFY. AND AS AN
ADVOCATE OF COURSE I'M GOING TO
MAKE AN ASK. I WON I WON ASK
VERY VERY VERY RESPECTFULLY TO
PLEASE COME OUT STRONG AGAIN
SEE UC'S PARTNERSHIPS WITH
RELIGIOUS HOSPITALS THAT-RESTRICT CARE TO PATIENTS.
BECAUSE INCREASE MARKET SHARE
SHOULD NEVER BE A REASON TO
ABANDON OUR STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO EQUALITY. BECAUSE INCREASE
MARKET SHARE SHOULD NEVER BE A
REASON OUR TAX DOT DOLLARS
SUBSIDIZE. DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST LGBT Q. PEOPLE. AND
THOSE SEEKING REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. BECAUSE INCREASE
MARKET SHARE SHOULD NEVER BE A
REASON TO PUT PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND WELL BEING IN DANGER. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISTER
MINTON FOR THAT INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL TESTIMONY I WANT YOU
KNOW THAT I'M SURE I SPEAK FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS AND DíAS AND
I SAY WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY AS WELL
AND- YOUR BRAVERY JUST. IS
INCREDIBLE AND I KNOW THIS IS
HARD FOR YOU ARE ROLE MODEL TO
SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO STRUGGLE WITH THINGS.
I THINK. NOW I WILL TURN OVER
TO. THE YOU SEE HAITIAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING US
TODAY MY NAME IS LISA IT CAMO
TERM A FACULTY MEMBER OF THE UC
DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW MY PRIMARY
AREAS OF WORKER REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS AND JUSTICE HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES IN BIOETHICS. I'M
GONNA TALK ABOUT TWO TOPICS SO
ONE IS THE ONGOING DEBATE ABOUT
THE AFFILIATIONS BETWEEN YOU
SEE MEDICAL CENTERS AND
HOSPITALS IT RESTRICTS
SERVICES. BASED ON RELIGIOUS
DOCTRINE AND ALSO THE IMPACTS
OF RELIGIOUS RESTRICTIONS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- SO BY
THE WAY BACKGROUND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE UC HEALTH CARE
TASK FORCE IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
ADVISES. THE UC COMMITTEE ON
FACULTY WELFARE ABOUT EMPLOYEE
HEALTH PLANS AS WELL AS
ACADEMIC. RESEARCH AND CLINICAL
ISSUE AND HEALTH AND MEDICINE.
AND MANAGEMENT OF YOU SEE
HEALTH SYSTEMS SO I'M NOT
SPEAKING HERE OF TODAY AS A
MEMBER OF THE TASK FORCE BUT
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT BACKGROUND ABOUT HOW THIS
ISSUE AROSE. TO THE UC SYSTEM-
SO I'M SPEAKING AS A LEGAL
SCHOLAR HIS RESEARCH THE ROLE
OF TOPIC HEALTH SYSTEMS- IN THE
US SINCE THE MID NINETEEN
NINETIES. I'M SO THE TASK FORCE
STARTED OF DISCUSSING CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
JUST FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND INITIALLY
WE FOCUSED ON NETWORKS
EFFICIENCY EMPLOYEE HEALTH
PLANS. SO THE QUESTION WAS
WHETHER EMPLOYEES WERE CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS IN THEIR MANAGED CARE
NETWORKS. HAD SUFFICIENT ACCESS
TO FULL SCOPE OF CARE. THAT
THEY NEED WE HAVEN'T QUITE
RESOLVED THAT YET. THEN IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN USED YES I
HAVE. NOW THAT HAD FORMALIZED
AN AFFILIATION WITH THREE
DIGNITY HEALTH HOSPITALS IN THE
AREA. I AND TWO. EIGHTEEN T.
STUDENTS AND OTHER ADVOCATES.
AT UCSF CHALLENGE THAT PROPOSED
AFFILIATION. SO IT. THE
HEALTHCARE TASK FORCE THEN TOOK
UP THAT ISSUE- SO IN RESPONSE
THE COMMITTEE ON FACT WELFARE
SET UP A STEP COMMITTEE. CALL
THE NON DISCRIMINATION AND
HEALTH CARE TASK FORCE LAURIE
FRIEDMAN AND I WERE BOTH
MEMBERS. OF THAT TASK FORCE OR
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT SUBCOMMITTEE
ROTARY. THAT I CONCERNS IN
CONFLICTS CAN ARISE WHEN THE
YOU SEE HEALTH CENTERS
AFFILIATE WITH HOSPITALS. FOUND
BY THE ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES FOR CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. THE TASK FORCE
ISSUED A REPORT LAST SUMMER.
THE FACULTY COUNCIL ENDORSED
THAT REPORT AND THEN FORWARDED
IT TO YOU SEE PRESIDENT OF
APOLLO TANA ON JULY THIRTIETH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. SO THE
TASK FORCE REPORT- INCLUDES A
SERIES OF KEY FINDINGS AND THEY
INCLUDE THE STATEMENT. THE
MISSION VALUES AND POLICIES OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AS
EXPRESSED IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. REGION'S POLICIES
AND ACADEMIC PERSONNEL MANUAL
ARE IN CONFLICT WITH THE USE OF
RELIGIOUS BELIEF FOR SECTARIAN
DOCTRINE. THAT RESTRICTS OUR
EXPENSE HEALTH CARE AND
DISCRIMINATORY WAYS. THE TASK
FORCE REPORT IDENTIFIES
POTENTIAL HARMS TO THE UC'S
MISSION AND VALUES ITS ABILITY
TO TRAIN MEDICAL STUDENTS. ITS
FACULTY ITS ABILITY TO DELIVER
EVIDENCE BASED HEALTH CARE AND
TO ITS PATIENTS. IN THE LAST
SECTION THE REPORT SETS OUT
PRINCIPLES FOR AVOIDANCE OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HEALTH CARE.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO LIST THEM
ALL BUT I'LL MENTION TO. IN
SIMPLE TO STATES THE UNIVERSITY
SHOULD NOT BE A MEMBER IN AN
ENTITY THAT PROVIDES HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WITH ANOTHER
MEMBER THAT HAS DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES. ARE POLICIES AND
HEALTH CARE. AND THEN THE
SECOND ONE PRINCIPLE FOR THE NO
MENTION. OF STATES IN PART ALL
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS ENTERED
INTO BY THE UNIVERSITY TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
SHOULD AFFIRMATIVELY INCLUDE
TERMS THAT REQUIRE FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THEUNIVERSITY
PRINCIPLES VALUES AND PRACTICES.
SO THE ISSUE MOVE FORWARD OR UP
REALLY IN FALL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN PRESIDENT APOLLO TANO
SET UP A WORKING GROUP TO
CONSIDER THESE ISSUES.
PROFESSOR GOOD WHEN AS YOU
HEARD WAS A MEMBER OF THE
WORKING GROUP. OF THE WORKING
GROUP DID NOT DEVELOP A
CONSENSUS- WE EXPECTED THE
REPORT IN DECEMBER IN AS A
STRUGGLE TO FIND THE CAME OUT
IN LATE JANUARY- SO RATHER IT
ISSUE THE CHAIR'S REPORT AND
LETTER SUBMITTED BY INDIVIDUALS
OR SMALL MEMBERS OF THE WORKING
GROUP. IN THE MEANTIME THE
ACLU'S WHOSE USE OF THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REVEALED THAT EVERY
YOU SEE HEALTH CARE CENTER-
HAVE AFFILIATION AGREEMENTS
WITH HOSPITALS THAT USE THE E.
R. TEASE OR ETHICAL RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES. AND THAT BOUND UC
FACULTY AND STUDENTS TO ABIDE
BY THE E. R. DISS BUT BOTH
PROFESSOR GOOD ONE AND AT THE
NET AND HAVE MENTIONED. THE
CHAIR'S REPORT WAS ISSUED AS I
SAID IN LATE JANUARY. OPTION
AND WHAT IT DOES IS IT SETS OUT
TWO OPTIONS- WAYS OF GOING
FORWARD OPTION ONE WOULD ALLOW
AFFILIATIONS WITH HOSPITALS THE
PROHIBITS SERVICES FOR WOMEN
WOMEN. AND FOR LGBT Q. PEOPLE
OPTION TWO WOULD EFFECTIVELY
PRECLUDE THOSE PLUGS PRECLUDE
THOSE AFFILIATIONS SO THESE TWO
OPTIONS ARE NOW SHAPING THE
DEBATE THAT'S TAKING PLACE AND
AS EVAN MINT MENTIONED THE
REGIONS ARE SCHEDULED TO
CONSIDER THEM IN MAY OF THIS
YEAR. SOME GONNA SPEND A FEW
MINUTES TALKING ABOUT THOSE TWO
OPTIONS I'M NOT GONNA DESCRIBE
THEM IN GREAT DETAIL BUT
MENTION A COUPLE OF POINTS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE. THE
BOTH OPTIONS OUT OVERLAPPING
BUT NOT I DON'T LIST OF SEVEN
PRINCIPLES EACH. EACH PRINCIPLE
IS ACCOMPANIED BY A GUIDELINE
AND I'M JUST GOING TO MENTION
TWO OF THE WHAT I THINK ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES. THAT
ARE DISCUSSED IN EACH OF THE
OPTIONS AND POINT OUT THE WAYS
IN WHICH THEY DIFFER. SO ONE IS
NON DISCRIMINATION BOTH OPTION
ONE AND OPTION TO STATE THE
PRINCIPLE OF NON
DISCRIMINATION- BOTH GUIDELINES
WOULD REQUIRE AFFILIATES TO
HAVE AN EXPRESS INSTITUTIONAL
POLICY PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION. ON ALL GROUNDS
ADDRESS BY STATE LAW AND YOU
SEE VALUES. HOWEVER OPTION TO
AN OPTION TO WAS THE ONE THAT
WILL EFFECTIVELY PRECLUDE
AFFILIATIONS BETWEEN YOU SEE IN
THE CATHOLIC HOSPITALS OR
OTHER. RELIGIOUS HOSPITALS THAT
HAVE RELIGIOUS RESTRICTIONS ON
HEALTH CARE OPTION TWO IS
GUIDELINE WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THAT AFFILIATION AGREEMENTS.
STATE THAT YOU SEE CONSIDERS
POLICIES THAT PROHIBIT GENDER
AFFIRMING SERVICES. FOR DURANT
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ABORTION AND
OTHER REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES. THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT WOMEN
IN LGBT PEOPLE TO VIOLATE YOU
SEE ANTI DISCRIMINATION POLICY.
THE SECOND PRINCIPLE I'M GONNA
MENTION A GUIDELINE THAT I'M
GONNA MENTION ADDRESSES
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CARE. SO
BOTH OPTIONS A FIRM THE GOAL OF
REDUCING BARRIERS TO ACCESS-
TWO CARAT YOU SEE HEALTH.
OPTION ONES GUIDELINES STATES
YOU SEE WILL EVALUATE POTENTIAL
AFFILIATIONS IN THE CONTEXT OF
UC'S COMMITMENT TO OPTIMIZE
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE NON
DISCRIMINATORY EVIDENCE BASED
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS. TO IMPROVE
HEALTH FOR ALL PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA YOU SEE HEALTH
WILL CONSIDER ALL ASPECTS OF AN
ORCHID ORGANIZATIONS CARE IN AN
AFFILIATION INCLUDING ONE
POLICY BASE RESTRICTIONS TO.
SERVICE TO THE UNDERSERVED AND
THREE THE AVAILABILITY OF OTHER
FACILITIES WITHIN A GEOGRAPHIC
REGION. ADVOCATES FOR THE
AFFILIATIONS HAVE FOCUSED ON
SERVICES TO THE UNDERSERVED AND
YET AS LAURA FRIEDMAN MENTION
NATIONAL DATA SHOW THAT WHILE
CATHOLIC SERVICES ARE MEDICAID
HOSPITALS. THEY DO NOT PROVIDE-
HIGHER LEVELS OF CHARITY CARE
THAN PUBLIC HOSPITALS IN EVEN
SOME FOR PROFIT SYSTEMS. OPTION
TWO SKYLINE ON EXPANDING ACCESS
TO CARE STATES THAT YOU SEE.
WILL EVALUATE POTENTIAL
pAFFILIATIONS AND TAKE NECESSARY
ACTION TO PROMOTE AND NOT
PROHIBIT OR LIMIT HEALTH CARE
OPTIONS. TO ENSURE THE ACCESS
TO SERVICES INCLUDING ABORTION
CONTRACEPTION ASSISTED
REPRODUCTIVE TECHNOLOGIES AND
GENDER FROM CARE FOR
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ARE
MAINTAINED OR IMPROVED AS A
RESULT OF THE AFFILIATION. YOU
SEE WILL ENSURE THAT
AFFILIATIONS DO NOT RESULT IN A
DECREASE IN THE ABILITY OF YOU
SEE PATIENTS TO OBTAIN THE
SERVICES AND FACILITIES WHERE
THEY RECEIVE CARE COMPARED WITH
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES PRIOR TO
THE AFFILIATION. SO THE OPTION
TO GUIDELINES ARE MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT THE SERVICES THAT ISSUE.
AND THEY PROVIDE A STANDARD
AGAINST WHICH TO MEASURE IMPACT
OF AFFILIATIONS. AND THEY
MANDATE ACTION AS OPPOSED TO
OPTION ONES REQUIREMENT THE
FACTOR SIMPLY BEACON CENTERED.
SO I WANT TO SPEND JUST A
MINUTE OR TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO QUALITY
OF CARE BY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. SAID THOSE WHO ARE
ADVOCATING FOR AFFILIATIONS
WITH HOSPITALS THAT USE THE
ETHICAL AND RELIGIOUS
DIRECTIVES ON HEALTH CARE. HAVE
BEEN HIGHLIGHTING THE GOAL OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY POSIT THE CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS AS- THE POSITION A
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS AS VEHICLES
TO EXPAND UC'S ABILITIES. TO
PROVIDE CARE TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AS AN ASIDE IT'S A
LITTLE IRONIC BECAUSE SOME OF
THE UC MEDICAL CENTERS
INCLUDING UC DAVIS MY HOME
SCHOOL. HAVE HAD AN ON AND OFF
RELATIONSHIP MEDI CAL- THEY
HAVE CONSISTENTLY BEEN ACCEPTED
MEDICAID PATIENTS. CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS AS I MENTIONED ARE
MEDI CAL OR MEDICAID HOSPITALS
THEY DO PROVIDE CARE FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE. ENROLLED IN
MEDICAID- JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
DATA AMONG NON ELDERLY MEDI CAL
ENROLLEES IN CALIFORNIA. 7% OR
BLACK AN AFRICAN AMERICAN 60%
ARE LEFT IN ACCESS. AND 10% ARE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER. MANY
MEMBERS OF THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE ALSO LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER THE BARRIERS
THEY FACE TO NON DISCRIMINATORY
FULL SERVICE CARE OFTEN GREATER.
62% A MEDI CAL ENROLLEES IN
CALIFORNIA- IDENTIFIED AS WOMEN
AND MANY WOMEN AND ROLLING MEDI
CAL WHEN THEY BECOME PREGNANT.
EITHER BECAUSE THEY ARE SEEKING
PRENATAL SERVICES AND SOMEONE
ROLE BECAUSE THEY ARE SEEKING
ACCESS TO ABORTION. NATIONALLY
PATIENTS WHEN MEDICAID COVERAGE
ARE LARGELY IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN.
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR-
PROFESSOR FRIEDMAN MENTION THE
STUDY A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
STUDY COMPARING FAITH. EXAMINE
THIRD FOUR STATES AND FOUND
THAT IN NINETEEN STATES WOMEN
OF COLOR MORE LIKELY THAN WHITE
WOMEN TO GIVE BIRTH AT
HOSPITALS. BOUND BY THE E. R.
D.'S. SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT HOSPITAL'S BOUND BY THE E.
R. T.'S MIGHT BE PROVIDING CARE
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
BUT IN DOING SO THEY PUT HE
MAJORITY OF THOSE PATIENTS AT
RISK OF LESS THAN STANDARD CARE
AND EXCLUSION FROM NECESSARY
SERVICES. SO THE LOGIC OF THOSE
WHO ARE SUPPORTING AFFILIATIONS
ONLY WORKS IF YOU IF YOU
SACRIFICE THE HEALTH NEEDS. OF
WOMEN AND LGBT Q. PATIENTS.
SELLING CLOSING I JUST WANT TO
QUOTE A BRIEF STATEMENT THAT'S
IN THE REPORT THAT WAS ISSUED
BY THE NON DISCRIMINATION AND-HEALTH CARE TASK FORCE. QUOTE
IT IS ANTITHETICAL TO THE
UNIVERSITY'S VALUES. TO ENGAGE
IN ANY ACTIVITY THAT WILL LIFT
SOME BUT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
OTHERS. THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT INSIGHT I
ONE OF THINK SOME LIMóN LOW
MOAN RECOGNIZE HER FOR JOINING
US. WE DO HAVE QUITE THE PANEL
OF ADVOCATES ON THIS ISSUE HERE
TODAY WITH US AT THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE AND MISS THEM
OUT IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR REMARKS I TURNED OVER TO YOU
THANK YOU. WELL I WON IT IT
KNOWLEDGE AND THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE- IT'S NOT LOST
ON ME THAT THE THREE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HERE ARE ALSO PART OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS- AND SO AT
NOT THAT THAT YOU KNOW WE DID
HAVE A INCREDIBLE ALLIES THAT
WERE HERE EARLIER AND- ARE
EQUALLY AS ENGAGE- BUT I
APPRECIATE. THE RECOMMENDATION
OF AS ADVOCATES WILL YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE ASK WHAT ARE WE
LEFT TO DO I THINK- ALL THREE
OF US IS I RECOGNIZE HAVE
SIGNED ON TO LETTERS HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW PUBLICLY IT. WHERE OF
THE- PLANTATIONS THAT WE ARE
SEEN THESE WORKAROUNDS THAT
WERE SEEN. THAT LIMIT CHOICE.
I'M IN A VERY TRUE WAY- AND SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS FOR US
THAT WE CAN EITHER. THINK ABOUT
DOING OURSELVES OR THAT WE CAN
TAKE BACK TO A CAUCUS THAT HAS
BEEN. ON THE FOREFRONT OF ST-
KENO HEALTH CARE. ALTOGETHER
COMPLETELY. COMPREHENSIVE IS
WHAT WE WORK FOR NOT. PARTIAL
IT OUT YOU KNOW. WHAT IS LOOK
LIKE HOW CAN WE BE HOW. ON AS
LIKE JUST. A THINK EVERY YEAR I
MEAN. I KNOW A SUMMER KAMLAGER
IS RUNNING A BILL IN THIS
MOMENT ON THIS VERY ISSUE ABOUT
COVERAGE IN INCREASING. SO
WE'RE ALL TRYING IN EVERY WAY
WE CAN BUT WHAT ELSE. CAN WE
SPECIFICALLY DO YOU- RIGHT NOW
THIS YEAR- WHAT CAN WE TAKE
BACK TO A CAUCUS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SO AGAIN I'M
PHILLIP BURLINGAME WITH THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA I'M- YOU
KNOW IT IT'S- THIS IS SUCH A
TRICKY ISSUE BECAUSE ON THE ONE
HAND AS WE'VE ALL DESCRIBED
THIS IS SUCH A MONUMENTAL
PROBLEM IN OUR STATE. AND YET
THE STAKES ARE ALSO VERY HIGH-
IN TERMS OF MAKING- ON SORT OF
A MISSTEP WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS WE
HEARD THE FIRST PANEL TALKING
ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH- ON THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE COURTS
ARE SORT OF X. INTERPRETING
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM- YOU KNOW
VERY BROADLY MUCH MORE BROADLY
THAN. THAN WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE- IN IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
ON. I KNOW I DO THINK THAT AS
EVAN- OF AND- LISA WERE SAYING
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT IN THIS MOMENT IS TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REMAINS A STRONG. SORT OF
BULWARK AGAINST THE
ENCROACHMENT OF- RELIGION
PARTICULARLY AS A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE REALLY DO FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT ON THAT
LEGISLATORS CAN- CAN DO IS
PARTICIPATE AS- AS THOUGHT
LEADERS AS- VûI AS LEADERS OF
THE- YOU KNOW MOVEMENT TO IN
CALIFORNIA TO SAY ABSOLUTELY
NOT YOU SEE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO IS PROBLEMATIC AND I. AND
I KNOW YOU BUT I JUST THINK.
YOU KNOW RE. IT'S REALLY IN. I
WOULD THEY ALSO THAT. YOU KNOW
FUNDED THERE'S REALLY ABOUT
SHE'S A THIRTY. ARMED AND THE
ROLE THAT BEEN ABLE TO PLAY IN
REALLY DIGGING AND TO THE
CONSOLIDATION AND EXPANSION OF-
OF A THE SYSTEMS AND YOU KNOW
HOLDING SETTING SOME CRITERIA
FOR PARTNERSHIPS- THEIR-
AUTHORITY RIGHT NOW IS LIMITED
TO NONPROFIT HEALTHCARE
INSTITUTIONS SO IF THERE IS A-
AN INVOLVEMENT AT A MERGER
LEVEL WITH A FOR PROFIT ENTITY
OR A PUBLIC ENTITY THAT AG
DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE
AUTHORITY OVER THAT SO I KNOW.
THAT SOMETHING THAT CURRENTLY
ARE BEING DESCRIBED AS WELL.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT
ON REGARDING HOW DELICATE THE
SITUATION IS IN THAT. EVEN AN
UNINTENDED MISHAP CAN HAVE A
CONSEQUENCE THAT WE ARE NOT
LOOKING FOR- SO I APPRECIATE
YOU SAYING THAT. THANK YOU MISS
LIMóN AND- AS ALWAYS THANKS
FOR BEING OUR INCREDIBLE VICE
CHAIR WHO LEADS THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN THIS FIGHT EVERY DAY.
MISS COLLARED GIVE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS I SENT THE WRONG PART
OF HERE BUT- I'M- SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU ALL FOR-
SHARING YOUR TESTIMONY AND YOUR
STORIES AND- TO EVAN AS YOU
WERE TALKING YOU SAID- YOU KNOW
THIS PART ISN'T SAD AND I WANT
YOU TO ACTUALLY KNOW THAT NO
PART OF WHAT YOU SAID WAS SAD.
ALL PARTS OF WHAT YOU SAID WAS
EMPOWERING ARM AND SO PLEASE
TAKE THAT WITH YOU- I WATCHED
YOU. SPEAK BEFORE CONGRESS AND
YOU ARE OUR STATE CHAMPION ON
THIS ISSUE. SO I WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT MY FRIEND- MY TWO
QUICK QUESTIONS ARE. IN THIS IS
YOU'LL HAVE TO JUST BE VERY
QUICK- BECAUSE IT'S A OF A LOT
OF LARGE QUESTION BUT WHICH
PRINCIPLE IS SUPER SETON. IS IT
THE PRINCIPLE OF THE US
CONSTITUTION OR THE E. R. D. OF
THE CHURCH. BECAUSE THE
CONSTITUTION INCLUDES THE UC
SYSTEM BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES I
WOULD ARGUE STATE FUNDING. YOU
KNOW THROUGH MEDI CAL AND HOW
WE DELIVER SERVICES. AND SO IN
YOUR ESTIMATION WHICH IS I KNOW
THIS IS A LEGAL QUESTION
PROBABLY A CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION BUT WHICH ONE. IS
SUPER SEASON
LAWYER THE PANEL- COME WRESTLE
YOU FOR. SO THE E. R. DID GET
TO PREVAIL BECAUSE OF A FEDERAL
STATUTE. OF THE FEDERAL STATE
YOU CAN BE CHANGED AND SO I
WOULD ENCURAGE YOU RIGHT AS
AND EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM TO
ADVOCATE. FOR MODIFYING THE
SCOPE OF- THE WELTON ACTRESS
KNOWS CODES ACT AND THE CHURCH
ACT- THAT'S WHAT STARTED THIS
BALL ROLLING SUCH A LARGE
EXTENT WE'VE GOT THESE FEDERAL
STATUTES PROTECTING THE ABILITY
NOT JUST OF INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDERS. RIGHT BUT OF NOW
CONSOLIDATED HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS- TO WIELD THIS CLUB-
THE POINT I WANTED TO MAKE IN
RESPONSE TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOANS QUESTION WAS. WHAT
LAW A LARGE PART OF WHAT TO
STAKE IS THE STANDARD OF CARE.
SO HUGE PERCENTAGE OF PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE TRAINED AT
THE UC SYSTEM MMHM- AND SO
THEIR TRAINING IS AFFECTED- BY
THESE AFFILIATIONS THAN IT
AFFECTS THE STANDARD OF CARE
FOR EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST THOSE WHO RECEIVING CARE
IN THE DIGNITY HOSPITALS. I
MEAN CERTAINLY THE UC PROVIDERS
SHOULD BE PROVIDING THE BEST
EVIDENCE BASED CARE AVAILABLE.
I JUST WANT TO JUMP IN IF I CAN
FOR ONCE AGAIN ON YOUR QUESTION
I'M- I THINK THAT IT'S- YOU
KNOW AS I WAS TRYING TO KIND OF
POINT OUT. THESE HOSPITALS
EXIST THEY'RE SORT OF TRYING TO
PLAY DUAL ROLE RIGHT WHEN THEY
WANT TO BE A HOSPITAL THEY SAY
OVER A HOSPITAL MORE PROVIDING-
CHARITY CARE AND CARE TO
MEDICAL PATIENTS AT CETERA- AND
WHEN THEY WANNA. SORT OF SITE
THEIR RELIGIOUS. RATIONALE FOR
THE CARE THEY PROVIDE THEN THEY
GOING TO THIS PLACE WHERE THEY
SAY WELL WE'RE REALLY KIND OF
LIKE A CHURCH- I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE- WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IT. TO SAY OKAY IF YOUR
HOSPITAL EXISTING IN THE SPACE
THEN. YOU NEED TO COMPLY WITH
THE LICENSING LAWS OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION. LAWS AND SO
SORT OF WITH IT. INSTEAD OF
SORT OF STEPPING UP TO THESE
LOOK BIG CONVERT BIG
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM AND THAT CENTER RIGHT
TO SAY OKAY AS A HOSPITAL
EXISTING WITHIN THIS REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK IN CALIFORNIA WHAT
ARE YOU DOING. AND NOT DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE ABIDING
BY THESE RULES AND NOT
DISCRIMINATING- I WOULD SAY
ALSO THE MEDI CAL- QUESTION IS
A LITTLE COMPLICATED BECAUSE
IT'S A REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED. OPPOSE LOOK
AT THE STATE WAS DOING
PROVIDING HUGE GRANTS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT MIGHT
BE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
SCENARIOS THAN IF THE
HOSPITAL'S ALREADY PROVIDED THE
SERVICES JUST SEEKING
REIMBURSEMENT- IT MAKES THE
PUBLIC FUNDS. MEANT A LOT MORE
COMPLICATED. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK THAT THE QUESTION
LEVERAGE FUND VAN ARE SORT OF
VOTE THEE'S I'M NO WAY CLOT SO
THAT YOU KNOW ARE THEY
VIOLATING THAT HE'S I THINK IS
A LITTLE MORE OF A COMPLICATED
QUESTION IN MY SECOND QUICKER
QUESTION AND GIVEN WHAT MISS
LOAN MENTIONED AND YOUR
RESPONSES IS NO I ACTUALLY-
EIGHT MY BILL A- SEVENTY THREE
WE GET WE CROSSED THE DESK OF
TODD COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND IT'S
A NO COST SHARING BILL. FOR
REFER TO HELP LES. I'LL OF NO
OF I'LL FROM THE TRI AND- SO
WHATEVER. BUT I. WENT SO WHEN
DO WE NOT FIGHT THEN BECAUSE.
MY AS THE I'M LEARNING ABOUT
ALL OF THE THINGS THE INSIDIOUS
PERVASIVE NUANCED COMPLICATED
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING MAYBE
AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT ALSO AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. AND YOU WE
DON'T WANT TO CHERRY PICK. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING
GLOBAL CONVERSATIONS BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT. YOU JUST HAVE
TO USE THE LEVERAGE OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE LAW AND
YOU FIND YOUR STANDING- BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THAT WE ARE
BECOMING OVERWHELMED BY. THE
LARGESS OF SORT OF BATTLES THAT
WE SEE AND SO DO YOU LAY DOWN.
OR DO YOU FIND THE SPACE TO
FIGHT. AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
ALSO MAYBE A LARGER QUESTION
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN DO YOU NOT
FOR THE IS THERE AN INSTANCE
WHERE YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO FIGHT. BECAUSE EVAN
STORY EVAN STORY CAN BE SHARED
BY SO MANY FOLKS WHO ARE
TRANSGENDER WHO ARE POOR WHO
ARE BLACK WHO ARE BROWN WHO ARE
WOMEN. I MEAN I THINK MY
RESPONSE TO THAT AND YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE UP ALL THE
SPACE FOR RESPONSES BUT MY
RESPONSE IS THAT I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS PANELIST IS
FIGHTING I MEAN WE ALL BELIEVE
IN AND FIGHTING- AND WE'RE ALL
DOING IT IN WAYS THAT I THINK.
YOU KNOW OUR INCREDIBLY MEANING
WELL I MEAN EVAN PROVIDE A
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY AND
THERE WAS THAT VIDEO OF I'M A
SEE THAT HAS BEEN SEEN BY OVER
MILLION PEOPLE NOW- WE'RE
INVOLVED WITH THE- PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND ENGAGEMENT
CAMPAIGNS SOLICIT MORE STORAGE
IS LIKE THE STORY OF MICHELIN
JOSH THAT WE EARLIER. I THINK
THE RESEARCH THAT- LAURIE IS
DOING AND THE- THE ENGAGEMENT
OF- ACADEMICS WITHIN- THE UC
SYSTEM IS REALLY IMPORTANT THE
LITIGATION IS IMPORTANT SO ALL
THE PIECES TOGETHER I THINK ARE
REALLY- ON CREATING- A CULTURE
OF INCREASING ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THESE INSTITUTIONS WHOLE
REVIEW THING WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE-
SO I WOULDN'T AT ALL I WANT TO
GIVE THE- RUSSIAN. AND BUSTER
SAYING. OUT THIS. RIGHT SO
LET'S. GO HOME I THINK IT THIS
FIVE THAT MOM REQUIRE. I A
VARIETY OF TACTICS AND- AND
WORK OVER THE LONG OVER THE
LONG TERM THAT WOULD BE MY
RESPONSE. BUT CAN I JUST SAY
THAT I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU-
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
TO ME HAPPENS TO EITHER
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY FOLKS
IN MY LIKE I'M VERY AWARE OF MY
POSITION AS- A TRANS GENDER
MALE. IN THE A OVERALL SPECTRUM
OF THE TRANS COMMUNITY AND LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME I'M VERY
PRIVILEGED IN MY OWN COMMUNITY
AND SELL- YEAH LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME IT HAPPENS TO
BLACK AND BROWN TRANS FOLK
DISPROPORTIONATELY WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU KNOW. WHO DON'T
HAVE THE RECOURSE IS THAT I HAD
YOU KNOW AND FOLKS WHO ARE I
HAVE. THE NOT HAVE THAT THE
CLASS THAT I'M PART OF AND
STUFF LIKE THAT INTO THANK YOU
FOR RECOGNIZING THAT BECAUSE
THAT IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. SO I MEAN THANK YOU
FOR NOT LOSING THAT. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'VE HEARD REPEATEDLY
TODAY IS THAT THIS AFFILIATION
IS TO SERVE THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND YET I WOULD
ARGUE THAT YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
AN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY WHO
IS. THE FURTHEST THING FROM
SERVE HERE THAT IT'S A WEIRD
POSITION TO BE IN YEAH AND AT
AT PRIVILEGE PERSON AND UNDER
VERY UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY.
YEAH I AM. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I AM AND I VERY MUCH
SHARE YOUR PHILOSOPHY WHICH IS
I MEAN WE'RE HAVING THIS
HEARING HERE TODAY BECAUSE IT
IS PART OF A FIGHT AND SHINING
LIGHT ON THIS ISSUE IN HEARING
THE STORIES. MAKING SURE THAT
HAVE IT MINES IN THAT ROOM TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION EQUIP US
AND OUR COLLEAGUES WITHOUT THAT.
PRETTY FLANK AND WE'RE NOT
GONNA LET THAT'S FOR. AB SO.
WHICH CHEST PIECE MOVES ALWAYS
THE- I'M SO IN A QUESTION AND-
THE UC AFFILIATION AT SO. ONE
OF THINGS WE HEAR IS YOU KNOW
WELL YOU'RE HAAS YOU SEE
HOSPITAL AND THEIR CAPACITY IN
DOWN THE ROAD YOU HAVE A- AM
CATHOLIC AT A HOSPITAL AND THEN
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE ANTI BAD IF
WE CAN MOVE THE PATIENTS WHO
WON'T BE AFFECTED BY POLICIES.
SO IT'S HARD TO KNOW WHETHER
THAT'S- REAL OR NOT. AND THEN.
YOU KNOW WE WOULD HAVE SPACES
ARE MORE PEOPLE IN THE UC I
GUESS MY QUESTION FOR YOU IS
COULD WE MOVE. TRANSFER THOSE
PEOPLE WITHOUT AFFILIATION IS
THAT A REAL ARGUMENTS I MEAN
I'M JUST TRYING TO PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S FOR. WITH A YOU. IS A FOLK.
AND THERE'S A DIGNITY YEAR I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SAN
FRANCISCO- VERSION OF THE SETS
COULD WE MOVE THOSE PATIENTS TO
THAT CTHOLIC HOSPITAL WITHOUT
THE AFFILIATION OR THEY TRACKED
AND YOU SEE HOSPITAL I GUESS I
DON'T SEE THE AFFILIATION IS
NECESSARY TO THE NEED THAT IS
BEING EXPRESSED TO ME. AND I
WONDER IF IT IS RARE. I MEAN.
SO I WOULD REALLY THIS
RATIONALES FOR THE- OKAY YEAH.
I MEAN IT SEEMS LIKE EACH
CAMPUS HAS THEIR OWN CLINICAL.
CAN OF SCENARIOS THAT COME UP
AND THEY CAN BE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT BUT- BUT- I THINK YOU
ASK A- GOOD QUESTION AND ONE OF
THE THAT. THINGS THAT I KEEP
WANTING. TO PUSH BACK IS WE
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANSWERS TO A LOT OF QUESTIONS-
AND SO THIS THIS. I THINK
BEFORE WE- CONSIDER OPENING THE
DOOR TO MORE- SORT OF CEMENTING
PARTNERSHIPS AND SORT OF
STRENGTHENING. THE CATHOLIC
SYSTEMS AS WELL IN THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT THE ALTERNATIVES ARE AND
WHAT THE REAL IMPACTS ARE SO. A
LOT OF THIS IS BEEN. M. SERVE
DISCUSSED IN THE ABSTRACT
WITHOUT REALLY GOOD DATA ABOUT
HOW MANY YOU SEE PEOPLE WOULD
END UP IN A YEAR THE HOT. BUT
ALL. I VICE VERSA. COURSE
URGENCY WE YOU KNOW PEOPLE
CAN'T BRING PATIENTS BACK AND
FORTH BUT WHAT THEY WANTED TO
DO WAS. A SITUATION WHERE WE
FIGURE LATELY I'VE MOST MY OF
OUR PAY. AND DIGNITY HOME AND
IN. CAN SERVE MORE PEOPLE AT
HIGHER HIGHER LIKE SPECIALTY-
NEEDS. SO I WOULD I WOULD URGE
YOU AND ME MY ASK MY BATES BE
TO REALLY QUESTION ON THE STORY
ABOUT. WHO WILL BENEFIT-
THROUGH AFFILIATION YEAH AND I
MEAN AS YOU HEARD FROM
PROFESSOR GOOD ONE OF HER VERY
SHORT NO WE HAVE NOT IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE WORK WAS NOT DONE TO
ANSWER ALL THE QUESTIONS US IS
VERY- AND SO THIS DICHOTOMY
THAT HAS BEEN SET UP BETWEEN
THESE TWO. POSITIONS THERE'S A
LOT IN THE MIDDLE THE NEEDS TO
BE DONE I BELIEVE YEAH SOUNDS
LIKE. THERE IS DEFINITELY. IS
THAT. THEY'RE SHIFTING FOLKS
WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO HEAR
THE ORGAN WILD RIGHT KNEE
REPLACEMENTS WITH EXAMPLE I
HEARD SO SIMILAR BUT YES SO BUT
THAT BEING SAID I GUESS MY
QUESTION WAS IF WE HAVE THOSE
KNEE REPLACEMENTS- CAN BE MOVED
IN WE HAVE A UCSF SOMEONE WHO
HAS SIGNIFICANT. HEART
TRANSPLANT NEEDS THAT ONLY CAN
BE THIRTY SAID CAN WE STILL
TRANSFER THAT KNEE REPLACEMENT
I GUESS I'M CONFUSED BY THE
NEED FOR THE VIOLATION IN ORDER
TO DO THAT. ALL ALL JUST-
QUICKLY SAY BEFORE THE EXPERTS
WAY AND- ON EITHER SIDE OF ME
BECAUSE I JUST HAVE MY OWN
STORY TO SHARE. BUT AND I GOT
LOST IN THE DIGNITY HEALTH
SYSTEM LIKE PEOPLE ARE GONNA
GET LOST REGARDLESS I WAS. ON
THE BOOKS AND THE DIGNITY
HEALTH SIT. IN AND- GENDER AND
THEN THEY IMMEDIATELY TOOK ME
OFF THE BOOKS. AND SO
REGARDLESS AB AND I REALLY LOOK
FOR CAN'T WHAT THE EXPERTS ARE
GONNA SAY. BACK AND REGARDLESS.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GET LOST IN THE SYSTEM AND
MISTAKES ARE GOING TO BE. EIGHT
AND ALL THREE OF. US OF THE
FACT THAT- YOU KNOW THERE'S A
40% TO. TEN GROUP IN THE TRANS
COMMUNITY. THAT NUMBER JUMPS
260% WHEN WERE DENIED. CARE YOU
KNOW. DUE TO ANTI TRANS BIAS.
SO I DON'T WANT ANY MISTAKES TO
BE MADE. AS IT IS A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH. ONE LORRIES
MADE THIS POINT REALLY
EFFECTIVELY BEFORE IS THAT NOT
EVERYBODY WHO HAS A HEART
CONDITION RIGHT IS A MAN. RIGHT
THEY MIGHT BE SOMEBODY FINDS
OUT THEY'RE PREGNANT- AND THEY
NEED CARE BECAUSE OF THAT. SO
THERE'S THAT CONCERN AS WELL
BUT THE OTHER IS YOU KNOW THE
STORY THE EVAN MEN RAISES THE
DIGNITARY CONCERNS SO YEAH YOU
COULD TRANSFER SOMEBODY WHO
NEEDS REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SOME OTHER SORT OF CARE THAT'S
PROHIBITED BY THE E. R. DIS. TO
RIGHT FROM THE FROM THE
CATHOLIC LITTLE TO THE UC
HOSPITAL SO THEY CAN RECEIVE
THAT BUT THE TRANSFER ITSELF
WAS SIGNATORY HARM. THE FACT
THAT IT'S SYSTEMATIC THE
IMPACTS ONLY CERTAIN
POPULATIONS IN THAT THAT'S
PREDICTABLE. IS PART OF WHOLE
THAT SIX PLACE AT WHY WE KEEP
USING THE WORD DISCRIMINATION
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY IT
VIOLATES BOTH THE VALUES OF YOU
SEE. ON THE STATE OF VALUES OF
YOU SEE AND THE VALUES OF THE
STATE SO YES IT'S TRUE YOU CAN
GO TO. I LIVE IN DAVIS RIGHT
THE HOSPITAL IN DAVIS IT'S NOT
A CATHOLIC HOSPITAL AND MIGHT
BE THAT THEY TRANSFER YOU
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A HUGE
HOSPITAL. SO THEY TRANSFER THE
TRAUMA PATIENTS SACRAMENTO FOR
EXAMPLE BUT THAT DOESN'T THAT
HITS PATIENTS RANDOMLY RIGHT IT
DOESN'T HIT THAT DIRECTLY BASED
ON THEIR IDENTITY. IS RULES
DIGITAL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
IT'S A MATTER OF LIKE CAN DOWN
IN THAT THE- NINERS SANTA. AND
I WAS. I SHOWED UP IN A
HOSPITAL AN APPENDECTOMY WITH
AN APPENDICITIS I WOULD BEEN
ONE OF THOSE ROUTINE CASES
TURNED OUT I WAS PREGNANT. AND
MY REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS BECAME
CENTRAL TO MEDICARE SO TO YOUR
POINT. IS NOT ALWAYS PEOPLE
SEEKING RETRACTED HAIR BE THAT
KIND OF GUIDANCE AS I DID
THROUGH MY TREATMENT. I'M SO I
AM I AND THIS GOES TO SOMETHING
THAT EVAN HAS SPOKEN ABOUT IN
GREAT DEPTH WHICH IS GETTING
ENDING UP RECAP ACOSTA- AND NOT
EVEN KNOWING THE LIMITATIONS
CASOS WILL YOU SPOKE ABOUT THAT
A LOT PROFESSOR FRIEDMAN IN
YOUR TESTIMONY YOU EXPLAIN MORE
ABOUT WHY PATIENTS ARE ENDING
UP AT THESE HOSPITALS AND DON'T
KNOW. AND THE RELIGIOUS RIGHT
SINCE THEY GO WITH IT. I CAN
SEE MY IN REAL QUICK AND IT WAS
COVERED BY MY INSURANCE AND
THAT'S WHERE AND IT WAS CLOSEST
IN THOSE CLOSEST HOSPITAL TO
ME. AND THAT'S WHERE MY DOCTOR
ALWAYS PERFORMS HER
HYSTERECTOMIES. AND SO SHE JUST
GOT WILL THAT THERE BECAUSE OF
A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR WAS ALSO
AN OBGYN. AND THERE'S NO
DISCLOSURE OF ANY. YEAH OUT
THERE- THERE ISN'T ANY KIND OF.
YOU KNOW I THINK LEGALLY AND
FORCED AGAIN PROTOCOL THAT'S-
UNIFORM THAT PATIENTS WOULD
KNOW TO LOOK FOR OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S SOMETHING IN WASHINGTON
STATE WHERE THEY'VE- ENDED A-
AS- LAW TO- TO. DEMAND
DISCLOSURE. BUT HIDDEN IN A
WEBSITE AND SO ANYWAY ONE OF
THE MAIN ANSWERS. AS THEY'RE
JUST IN A LIBRARY AT TO TAKE
THE RELIGIOUS SYMBOLS OUT OF
THE BRANDING AND A LOT OF
HOSPITALS AND IF YOU'LL
REMEMBER WHEN DIGNITY WAS
CATHOLIC HEALTHCARE WEST AND
BOTH MEN AND IT'S A LITTLE
CONFUSING DIGNITY DOESN'T SOUND
PARTICULARLY- RELIGIOUS TO MOST
PEOPLE AND I'M YOU KNOW A
CATHOLIC HEALTH INITIATIVES
WILL BECOME COMMON SPEAK IT IN
A CITY NAMES OR NAMES OF MOST
HOSPITALS HAVE KIND OF TAKEN
THAT THE SAINTS OUT OR THE- AS-
REALLY. THREE BUT OF INTERVIEWS.
THEIR WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY MANY OF THEM- CHRIS
CHEN RELATIVELY RELIGIOUS AND
THEY DON'T ANTICIPATE- MOST OF
THESE RESTRICTIONS AND THEY
OFTEN SAY- I JUST THOUGHT THE
LAW WITH THE LAW LIKE IF YOU'RE
A HOSPITAL YOU HAVE TO OFFER
THE LEGAL STUFF THAT'S A VERY
COMMON PERSPECTIVE THEY DON'T
EXPECT THEIR PHYSICIANS TO SAY
SORRY I'M BOUND BY THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH ONE THING I DO WANT TO
ADD IS THAT. IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A REQUIREMENT THAT.
INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE TO-
PROVIDE NOTICE WHEN THEY HAVE
HOSPITALS IN THE NETWORK THAT
ARE- RESTRICTING CARE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT FEW INSURANCE-
PLANS ACTUALLY DO IN A WAY
THAT'S TRANSPARENT AND VISIBLE
FOR ENROLLEES AND NOT COULD.IS
SOMETHING THAT- ADVOCATES IN
THE STATES HAVE TALKED ABOUT-
AWAY TO KIND OF UP THAT- KIND
OF PRESSURE ON THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES SO THAT FOLKS IN THE
SITUATION THAT EVANS AND WHERE
IT'S LIKE MY INSURANCE IS SENT
ME TO THIS HOSPITAL. ON AT
LEAST THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING
OF- WELL WHAT ARE THE
HOSPITAL'S WITHIN YOUR NETWORK
AND WHAT SORT OF SERVICES TODAY
PROVIDE AND THAT'S AN
OBLIGATION ON THE INSURANCE
PLAN ON ON POSSIBLE IT'S-
INTERESTING. AND THEN WE'RE SEE
YOU SPOKE ALSO PRESERVATION
ABOUT- CAB ACOSTA- SENDING
PATIENTS ELSEWHERE FOR CARE
WHERE DID THEY SEND THEM IF
THEY DO SEND THEM YOU KNOW IT'S
REALLY VERY ABLE AND PEOPLE
HAVE THEIR- YOU KNOW EACH HAVE
THEIR TRANSFER RELATIONSHIPS
AND THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES OF YOU
KNOW THE HIGHER LEVEL KERR NEAR
THEM- BUT ONE OF THAT REALLY
COMMON THEMES IN MY DATA WERE.
I'M DOCTORS WHO WHEN THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW NOT
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE POST
PARTUM CONTRACEPTION
STERILISATION THEY- OR EVEN
CLINIC CONTRACEPTION THEY SAY.
WELL ACTUALLY IT'S KIND OF IT'S
FINE BECAUSE WE CAN SEND THEM
TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD I JUST
TELL THEM TO GO TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. SO INTERESTING I'M-
AG CONNECTION CONSIDERING THE
FUNDING CHALLENGES PLANNED
PARENTHOOD'S HAVING- THAT
THEY'RE ALSO CARRYING THE WATER
FOR THESE DENIALS AND- SO WE
CAN SEE SERVE THE EGO SYSTEM I
REAP. HEALTH CARE AND PLACE
THIS. A LOT AT THE DESIGN I'M
IN A APOLOGY IF I MISS IT BUT
IS. IS WHEN THEY CANNOT PERFORM
THE MEDICAL NEED IS IT A 100%
OF THE TIME THAT THEY- REFER OR
IS THERE A PERCENTAGE OF THE
TIME LIKE DO WE KNOW. OKAY SO
IT WE DO NOT HAVE STATISTICS
ABOUT THAT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
I DO A LOT OF QUALITATIVE
RESEARCH AND GET A SENSE OF.
THE FACT THAT. HOSPITAL'S VERY
AND HOW THEY HELP PERMISSIBLE
THEY ARE TO SORT OF WORK
AROUNDS OR OR THE LIKE I SAID
ABOUT- SORT OF MAKING UP A NON
CONTRACEPTIVE REASON FOR
SOMETHING OR FOR THAT KIND OF
THING SO. SINCE SOME PLACES
HAVE A BY. SOME CIVIC. ON
CONTRACEPTIVE REASON FOR
SOMETHING AND OTHER DR OTHER
PLACES AND OTHER DOCTORS WOULD
TELL ME THAT IT HAS BECOME VERY
STRICT ACTUALLY STRANGELY QUITE
MORE STRICKEN IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS BECAUSE- THERE
WAS A BIG MOVEMENT WITHIN THAT
BISHOP AMONG THE BISHOPS- TO.
CLAMP DOWN ON TOO MANY
EXCEPTIONS TO THEIR
STERILIZATION POLICY THEY WERE
BEING DONE TO WIDELY AND SO. A
LOT OF LOT OF THE DOCTORS I
SPOKE WITH SAID YOU KNOW WHEN I
TOOK THIS JOB PEOPLE SAID IT
WAS NO BIG DEAL WE JUST HAD TO
DO A FORM THEY RUBBER STAMP IN
THE WE COULD DO THE
STERILIZATION BUT AT. A TO STOP
BEING A ALLOWED SO IT'S
UNFORTUNATELY NOT HARD DATA ON
THAT BUT QUITE A LOT OF VERY
ABILITY AND- AM. AND WHAT I
ALSO SENSED FROM THE DOCTORS
WAS JUST THAT YOU KNOW SOME
WERE EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT
PROVIDING VERY GOOD HERE AND
THEY WOULD MAYBE TRY TO. COME
NEW IN A SAYS. AS AS THE CUT.
IN A PREGNANCY. ARM AND THEN
THERE SOME PEOPLE. WHO JUST
SORT OF LOOK AT. OTHERS IT JUST.
WELL THANK YOU ALL CLOSE WITH
THE LAST QUESTION THAT AND
UNLESS YOU HAVE SOMETHING. THAT
I CLOSE WITHIN THE LAST PANEL
IF YOU HAVE ANY LAST ASKS FOR
US. YOU KNOW MISLIM OWN ASKED
WHAT WE COULD DO BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH THE QUESTION OF. HOW CAN
WE CONTINUE TO PROTECT-
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THESE VULNERABLE AND I WOULD
CALL UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS-
AND IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU
WOULD LEAVE US. I INVITE YOU TO
SELL. FIGHT FIGHT FIGHT. PLUS
ONE ON THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU I WE WILL OPEN IT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF ANYBODY HAS A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'RE WELCOME
TO COME UP THE MAKE IS OPEN.
LIKE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF PUBLIC
COMMA ON BEHALF OF SHANNON
HOVIS DIRECTOR OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA WHO'S HOME
SICK WITH JUST. REGULAR COLDS-
NARAL IS DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ISSUE OF HEALTH CARE
REFUSALS AND WANTS TO THINK
THAT SELECT COMMITTEE AND
CHAIRWOMAN. FOR HOLDING A
HEARING ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE. WHILE THERE ARE MANY
STRONG PROTECTIONS FOR LEGAL
RIGHTS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE IN THE STATE. THE
PROLIFERATION OF HEALTH CARE
REFUSAL SERVES TO SERIOUSLY
ENDANGER SLEE UNDERMINE ACCESS
TO REPRODUCTIVE ENGENDER
FRAMING CARE. TO GUARANTEE OUR
IT'S IN CALIFORNIA TRANSLATE TO
ME FULL ACCESS. THE STATE MUST
WORK TO STEM THE TIDE OF HEALTH
CARE FOR REFUSALS. PARTICULARLY
INSIDIOUS IS THE ENCROACHMENT
OF REFUSALS INTO THE PUBLIC
SPHERE. AT THE UC OF CALIFORNIA
AND ARE COUNTY AND DISTRICT
HOSPITALS. NARAL LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON REAL SOLUTIONS TO
THESE ISSUES THING AREA. HELLO
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND WE HEAR
TODAY IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
EXPERT COLLEAGUES IN THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SPACE. AS
WELL AS IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
FRIEND OF IN MEN TEN AND SO
MANY OTHERS WHO HAVE LENT THEIR
VOICE- AS TO HOW THE THESE
RESTRICTIONS IMPACT PEOPLE'S
LIVES- IN THE EIGHTIES YOU KNOW
BY THEIR OWN. WORDS ARE CLAIM
TO BE BASED ON A RECOGNITION OF
THE DIGNITY OF THE HUMAN
PERSON- HOWEVER AS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY. OF AND THEY DON'T SEEM
TO ALWAYS REFLECT. OF THAT
FOUNDATION PARTICULARLY IN
RELATION TO THE DIGNITY OF THE
LGBT Q. HUMAN PERSON- I'M-
SORRY ABOUT THE ROLE OF YOUR
KEYS AND NEED TO. TAX OF. AND
RIGHTS TAX THE CURRENT LEGAL
LANDSCAPE SO ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THIS CONVERSATION AND- WE DO
HOPE TO WORK WITH ALL PARTIES
IN IDENTIFYING. SOME AVENUE IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT AND PROTECT
AND RECOGNIZE THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. AND THE DIGNITY OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHY WHAT I THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE AND I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES WHO JOINED US
TODAY FOR THIS. I AM INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION I THINK
THAT THE NOTE WE CLOSED ON IS
THE ONE THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
HOME WHERE WE'RE NOT DOWN.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA FOR TAX
EVERYBODY'S RIGHT COMPREHENSIVE
CARE AND EVERYTHING THAT GOES
WITH IT SO. THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE. YES. WHAT IS AN
HONOR TO.